foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning
all right it's my understanding that
defense is resting is that correct all
right I'm not going to bring the jury
out just to take them back in So when
they after we finish our emotions and
they come out I'll let you say that yeah
okay let's just do it that way
all right so based on them resting you
have emotion
and I did receive your memo ahead of
time so I have reviewed that
okay
I think it's just gonna be oral
arguments
yes sir uh good morning your honor may
it please the court Ben Chu for
plaintiff Johnny Depp Mr Depp hereby
moves to strike defend an Amber heard's
counter claims
because Miss heard has not proven by
clear and convincing evidence that Mr
Waldman made the three allegedly
defamatory statements with actual malice
right but clear information is not my
motion to strike standard I understood
we have cited the standard in our brief
thank you uh moreover your honor the
court should also strike defendant's
claim for immunity and attorneys fees uh
based on Virginia's anti-slap statute as
she is not entitled to immunity under
the statue because we know that the
court has carefully reviewed our motion
papers I will just hit some of the
Salient points thank you sir thank you
honor I I would mention however uh your
honor that because this is not included
in our brief that there is no record
evidence whatsoever
that Mr Depp even saw any
of the three statements that Mr Waldman
made prior to being served with the
counter claims in this action which we
believe is relevant to many of the legal
standards and as your honor is aware Ms
heard had signaled for the past week
that she was planning to call Mr Depp in
her case in Chief
and it was our anticipation that she
would try to fill what we believe is a
gaping hole and with respect to the
elements of her proof again there's no
record evidence whatsoever that Mr Depp
ever saw any of the three statements
about which misheard is purportedly
suing him for a hundred million dollars
as your honor is aware the elements of
defamation are as follows one public
publication
of two an actionable statement with
three the requisite intent she thought
thought versus Sanders 280 285 Virginia
476 at 2013.
the requisite intent for defamation
against a public figure is actual malice
that is the statement must be made with
knowledge that it was false or with
Reckless disregard of whether it was
false or not
C Sanders V Harris 213 Virginia 369 at
372 a 1972 case
see also Jackson V Hartig 274 Virginia
at 2019.
Reckless disregard is your honor is
aware quote is not measured by whether a
reasonably prudent person would have
published or would have investigated
before publishing ellipses there must be
sufficient evidence to permit the
conclusion that the defendant in fact
entertains serious doubts as to the
truth of the of his publication unquote
Saint Ahmad versus Thompson 390 U.S
Supreme Court 727 at 7 31.
your honor the evidence shows that
misheard cannot Prevail on her claim
because she cannot and did not establish
that Mr Waldman made the statements with
actual malice
Mr Waldman testified that he conducted
extensive investigation and reasonably
reasonably believe that the three
statements he made were true
Miss heard presented nothing
nothing to contradict that Undisputed
fact
misheard has no evidence of direct
liability because obviously your honor
we need to talk about direct and
vicarious liability but it Bears noting
that she has no evidence of direct
liability and cannot prove actual malice
by Mr Waldman when making the three
statements at issue
it is Undisputed that Mr Depp did not
make any of the three statements at
issue in this Herb's counterclaim
moreover in order for Mr Depp to be
liable for the conduct of his one of his
attorneys there must be some showing
that he directed participated or
otherwise authorized Mr Waldman to make
the statements at issue there is no such
evidence on the record that Mr Depp
directed or otherwise authorized Mr
Waldman to make the three allegedly
defamatory statements
at issue in the counter claims indeed
there is no evidence of any
communication or coordination between Mr
Depp and Mr Waldman regarding the
counter claim statements or anything
else for this reason as well your honor
misheard cannot meet her burden of
proving that Mr Waldman was acting
within the scope of his employment as
our agency on behalf of Mr death
again it Bears noting that there's no
evidence that Mr Depp even saw the
statements by Mr Waldman until he was
sued served with the counter claims well
into this case it was more than a year
after Mr Depp filed his his complaint
and misheard lost a series of motions to
dismiss that she finally asserted her
counter claims most of which have
already been dismissed by opinion letter
of this court
where is here there is no evidence of
direct liability misheard must rely on
the theory of vicarious liability to
hold Mr Depp liable for the actions or
statements rather of his purported agent
Mr Waldman vicarious liability is by
definition quote liability for the tort
of another person unquote so to hold Mr
Depp liable for Mr waldman's statements
misheard must establish that Mr Waldman
himself committed all the elements of
defamation I know the Court's familiar
with this so I'll try to run through it
quickly
see Parker versus Carillon Clinic 296
Virginia 319 at 332 a 2018 case quote
vicarious liability is liability for the
tort of another person
it necessarily follows that a claimant
cannot make out a case for vicarious
liability against an employer without
first proving that the employee
committed a tort within the scope of his
employment
see also route and Pontiac Corp versus
Austin 236 Virginia 152 at page 156.
which standard misheard has not met and
your honor we cite a string site
citation to cases from other
jurisdictions which we obviously are not
binding on the court but we believe are
influential we presented those to the
court
um for its review
it is misheard's burden to prove by
clear and convincing
evidence
or ultimately uh to prove actual malice
by Mr Waldman not Mr dapp and while it
is well settled law in Virginia as your
honor has pointed out pointed out last
week
that an agent's knowledge can be imputed
to a PR a principle and this is the
Allen Realty Corp versus Hobart case 227
Virginia 441 at 446.
Ms heard's Council cannot cite any case
law stating that a principal's knowledge
is imputed to an agent in other words Mr
Waldman must have made the statements
knowing that they were false or with
Reckless disregard as to whether they
were false and Mr Depp's knowledge
cannot be imputed to him
there is no evidence in the record that
Mr Waldman knew the counterclaim
statements were false indeed Mr Waldman
did not even know Mr Depp or misheard at
the time of any of the alleged incidents
at issue and thus had no personal
knowledge of what transpired and this is
reflected in the trial transcript that
Mr Waldman
met Mr Depp first in October of 2016
long after the fact
nor is there any evidence in the record
that Mr Waldman subjectively entertained
any serious doubts about the falsity of
the counterclaim statements quite the
opposite the evidence shows and it's
unrebutted that Mr Waldman had very
reasonable grounds to believe and he did
believe and will to his dying debt that
misheard's claim of abuse were patently
false Mr Waldman testified at length
about 29 Witnesses he believed disproved
misheard's false claims of abuse
see the transcript at page
6008-6012 and it won't run through all
of that
but his testimony the two trained police
officers Officer signs and Haddon were
called to the penthouse on May 21 2016
and saw no signs of injury on this
heard's face as well as quote Miss
heard's own Witnesses who have testified
in various forms at various times that
there were no injuries to her face
whatsoever between May 21st and May 27
2016 when she walked in to court with
her publicist her lawyer her former best
friend who no longer speaks with her for
a no notice ex parte tro
some of the witnesses who Mr Waldman has
cited they include Laura divinir Melanie
inglesis who is your honor recalls is
was Miss heard's makeup artist who
decided to end any professional or
personal association with Ms heard
uh
Samantha McMillan Hilda Vargas Isaac
Baruch
Trinity Esparza Cornelius Harrell
Alejandro Romero and Brandon Patterson
just to name a few
no reasonable jury could find that Mr
Waldman acted with actual malice in
making the allegedly defamatory
statements he was not present for the
alleged incidents he has no personal
knowledge of any of the alleged
incidents what Mr Waldman knows is a
product of the legal work he did the
sleuthing he did on behalf
of Mr Depp
misheard cannot possibly show that Mr
Waldman with acted with actual malice
and her defamation claim must fail
two Mr Waldman is an independent
contractor not an employee
it is axiomatic your honor that a person
who hires an independent contractor is
not liable for the independent
contractor's actions see Sanchez versus
medicorp Health System 270 Virginia 299
at 344.
an independent contractor is a person
who is engaged to produce a specific
result but who is not subject to the
control of the employer Principle as to
the way to bring about that result
C Atkinson versus such no 261 Virginia
378 at 284. that's a 2001 case
an outside lawyer retained by a client
in connection with litigation is an
independent contractor C King versus
Dalton 895 f-sop 831 eastern district of
Virginia
1995.
where judge Ellis a legendary jurist
known by all Virginia practitioners held
that quote a law firm attorney working
with a client is nonetheless an
independent contractor and is not an
employee of the client Corporation in
that case the employer was the
corporation but the same logic applies
when it's an individual like Mr Depp
that was Mr waldman's role
indeed clients hire lawyers to obtain
specific results or to try to obtain
specific results but they do not control
the means by which the results are in
are accomplished lawyers as your honor
has reminded us are subject to
professional obligations to exercise
independent professional judgment we CA
we are not at the whim of our clients as
much as we want to serve them
see Virginia State Bar professional
guidelines rule 1 colon 2 and 2.1 and
just a quote 2.1 in representing a
client a lawyer shall exercise
independent professional judgment
unquote
Mr Waldman is as a matter of law an
independent contractor and Mr Depp
cannot be held responsible for any
alleged tort by
his attorney particularly for statements
about which
He was unaware until he was sued for
them
Mr Waldman testified and it's unrebutted
that he has an imp he has his own Law
Firm he's not an employee of Mr Depp Mr
Depp and or none of his loan out
companies have have issued him a W-2 and
Mr Waldman provides legal services to
clients other than in addition to Mr
death and that's found at the transcript
page 6020-21
all of that is unrebutted by misheard
Mr waldman's statements the third reason
for which we respectfully submit the
counterclaims should be stricken is that
Mr waldman's statements were protected
opinion and I won't run through all of
that but very briefly
taken in their proper context the
counter claim statements are
non-actionable expressions of opinion
entitled to protection under the First
Amendment see Gertz versus Robert
welchink 418 U.S 323 at 339 that's a
1974 case from the United States Supreme
Court
see also shocker be the fault a Virginia
Supreme Court case found at 290 Virginia
83 a 2 2015 case noting that where quote
all sides of the issue
as well as the rationale for the
speaker's view were exposed the
assertion of Deceit reasonably could be
understood only as the speaker's
personal conclusion unquote and finding
an accusation of Deceit to be opinion
in context your honor any reporter or
any reasonable reader would understand
and expect a lawyer associated with Mr
Depp as Mr Waldman was to challenge Miss
heard's version of the inherently
controversial events of the party's
marriage just as misheard's lawyers were
quoted challenging Mr Depp and your
honor will remember the context of these
quotes that were in a British tabloid
where Mr waldman's statements were
buried well into article in which both
points of view
were clearly expressed and Mr Waldman
was clearly identified not as an
independent expert on the U.S
Constitution but is one of of Mr Depp's
attorneys
us see Chavez
290 230 Virginia 112 at page 119 quote
the most unsophisticated recipient of
such Acclaim I.E any reader of the
British tabloid
made by a competitor against another
could only regard it as a relative
statement of opinion grounded upon the
speaker's obvious bias unquote Mr
Waldman has never done never did
anything to hide his support and of and
belief in Mr debt
finally your honor and for the rest uh
ultimately Mr waldman's statements
reflect the existence of two competing
narratives and are merely his subjective
View
about events that he never claims to
have witnessed and there was no doubt
about that
turning to the second part of the
argument which will be more abridged
misheard is not
entitled to anti-slap immunity as a
threshold matter Virginia code section
8.01-223.2
which is as your honor well knows is the
Virginia anti-slap Statute amended most
recently in 2019
provides in relevant part quote
the uh the immunity provided by the
section shall not apply to any
statements made with actual or
constructive knowledge that they are
false or with Reckless disregard for
whether they are false
here in addition to Mr Depp's testimony
several witnesses have testified that a
they never witnessed Mr Depp abuse
misheard and B that they observed
misheard without any injuries marks
bruising swelling Etc during periods
when misheard claimed to have injuries
marched bruises Etc
such Witnesses include but are not
limited to Isaac Bruce Kate James Dr
David Kipper nurse Debbie Lloyd officer
signs and Haddon Officer William Gatlin
and former U.S marine Starling Jenkins
Miss Hertz requests for anti-slap
immunity should be stricken and even if
there were disputing even if there were
disputed facts as to that
the anti-slap immunity does not apply
because the defamatory implication of
misheard statements are not solely
relating to a matter of public concern
as is required under the statute as has
become quite clear your honor Mr Depp is
not suing about any of the public policy
commentary made by the ACLU when it
drafted the op-ed and Miss heard put her
name to it
what he is suing about here are the
three statements that were directed at
him he has no issue with women's rights
he supports women's rights in fact he
was the one your honor as your honor
knows who made that first hundred
thousand dollar contribution to the ACLU
and he made it also
to the CHL your honor at this point I'm
going to object Mr two is largely just
read his brief and confined his
arguments to those directed in the
motion but like we saw with the last
motion to strike he's now directing his
arguments with something other than
what's at issue here and I would object
because I think making an argument not
to you but to the cameras it threatens
it's disrespectful to the court and
everyone's time and it also threatens to
undermine the Integrity of this process
and risk the jury being influenced by
outside factors well it's his argument
thank you thank you thank you
as I was trying to say
what Mr Depp is suing about are the
three statements and it's very clear
despite the pious opening statement that
about the first impendment that with the
testimony of Terence Doherty and the
emails that were admitted as exhibits
that the ACLU and misheard were
conspirable
to make it very clear that those three
statements were related to Mr deck
because otherwise nobody had any
interest in the article and it's it's
Crystal Clear from that they wanted to
time this thing with the release of
Aquaman which was her first film of any
significance in terms of
uh popularity and to do that that's very
clear so the charade that this had
something to do with public policy is
risible and that is not why the
anti-slab protections were enacted they
were enacted to protect the rest of the
article not what Mr Depp is suing about
as generally analyzed by the courts a
matter of public concern is one which
relates to quote a matter of political
social or other concern to the community
unquote as opposed to a matter of only
quote personal interest unquote that's
conic versus Myers 461 us-138 at page
146.
instead
the defamatory implication at issue in
each of the three states statements
at bar relate to the personal grievances
between Mr Depp and misheard which does
not rise to the level of a matter of
public concern with broader implications
for society beyond the two litigants in
this action anymore than Mr waldman's
statements
I mean
the adding the gloss of public policy
might immunize the statements that
relate to public policy but those are
not at issue here Mr Depp agrees with
those statements we're talking about the
three statements that they vary
intentionally and very cleverly
put in to make it clear the implication
that it was about Mr Depp they had
lawyers from the ACLU
working around the clock with Eric
George
to make to be as clever about this as
possible and your honor remembers the
testimony of Mr Doherty about the
consternation that the ACLU when they
realized that USA Today and everybody
else who read the article knew darn well
that this was about Mr Depp this cannot
be protected by the anti-slap statute it
is a cynical runaround and I think now
that we have the Undisputed evidence
from from the ACLU in the form of the
testimony of Terence Doherty who is not
only their corporate representative he
was their general counsel he is a
brainiac lawyer they knew exactly what
they were doing your honor and one of
the he referred to testimony of a woman
at the ACLU who said she had nightmares
about Miss hurt and he's expressed no
concern about that now that was either
because they knew about
was either a reference to this game they
were playing with the op-ed or the
conspiracy they had to cover up her
failure to make the donations
the donations became pledges but now but
we have evidence that she refused to
sign the pledge card
so she's caught either way
simply stated your honor Mr Depp is not
suing Miss heard for making statements
about Society in general I think that's
very clear from the record evidence
Mr Depp is suing her for publicly naming
him as an abuser by implication and
forever tarnishing his good name an act
that coming from an ex-spouse
is fundamentally personal in nature for
that reason as well your honor
Virginia's anti-slap statute is not
applicable and based on the for
foregoing your honor Mr Depp
respectfully submits that the court
should Grant plaintiff's motion to
strike the counter claims and also
Striker claim that she is immune under
the anti-slap statute thank you very
much
thank you your honor
as your honor knows the trial court is
required to accept us through all the
evidence favorable to Amber at this
point as well as any reasonable
inference a jury might draw there from
which would sustain the counter claim
that's the correct standard here I'll
address the actual malice argument first
the agency argument your honor there's
plenty of evidence in the record from
which the jury could determine that Mr
Waldman was Mr Depp's agent he made
those statements the statements referred
to him as Mr Depp's attorney as your
honor ruled on Friday with respect to
the jury instruction uh conference an
attorney is an agent of his client Mr
Waldman testified that he's been Mr
Depp's attorney since 2016.
uh he freely admitted speaking to the
Press on Mr Depp's behalf and he refused
to answer question after question about
that agency so we can't use that as a
sword now
uh Mr Chu puts a lot of emphasis on the
fact that Mr Depp allegedly didn't see
the comments that were made that are the
subject of the counterclaim but as your
honor well knows whether he saw them or
not is not the standard for agency
there's also evidence that Mr Depp met
with the Daily Mail with Mr Waldman
prior to the defamatory statements being
made and released I believe that was in
February of 2020 just two months prior
Mr Waldman also concocted a story that
Amber was being investigated for perjury
by filing a perjury complaint against
her with the LAPD he disregarded any
evidence that he didn't believe would
fit in his narrative that would fit in
this story that he was speaking about on
behalf of Mr Depp and after Mr death
lost the UK proceeding after Mr Depp was
ruled to be a wife beater by the court
in the united in the UK proceeding the
court there found him to be a wife
beater Mr Waldman then got an overseas
tabloid to run a story claiming that
Amber was being investigated for perjury
which simply wasn't true he walked into
the LAPD filed a complaint for perjury
against misheard found a media outlet
that doesn't follow the two Source Rule
and then he he had let the world believe
that the LAPD was investigating misheard
for perjury that's a shameful and a
sickening example your honor of the
links of Mr death through his agent Mr
Waldman would go to to smear and to fame
Amber Heard and that continued in the
three statements in the counterclaim
your honor has heard evidence I won't go
through all the evidence but your honest
heard evidence from Ron Schnell who's
traced the negative hashtags toward
Amber Heard online associated with those
defamatory statements and notedly noted
the staggeringly high number of them
that were associated with Mr Waldman
under the principles of the agent
principal relationship in Virginia your
honor when Mr Waldman made those
statements he was standing in the shoes
of Mr Depp they are one and the same for
the purposes of those statements as your
honor discussed at length on Friday Mr
Waldman made these statements with
actual malice there's plenty of evidence
from which the jury could infer that and
his own both from the actual malice from
Mr Depp and Mr waldman's own Reckless
disregard of facts that didn't support
Mr Depp and his attempts to manufacture
false evidence that did as your honor
found in the hearing I believe it was on
March 24th after your honor denied Mr
Depp's motion for summary judgment
your honor said as to malice a fact
finder could reasonably conclude that Mr
Waldman made the statements with malice
because Mr Waldman has no personal
knowledge of the party's marriage and
still made the statements at issue
nothing in this case has changed that if
anything the evidence has only made it
more clear that that is an inference
that the jury can and we believe will
find
um so your honor there's there's no
there's no basis to Grant a motion to
strike on this agency argument on the
actual malice argument the evidence
shows that Not only was Mr Waldman Mr
Depp's agent but that the two of them
conspired to falsely accuse Amber of
creating a hoax and falsify evidence
that they believed supported their their
Theory and what they wanted to achieve
um as your honor well knows too I won't
go through all the law but both agency
and Malice can be inferred through
circumstantial evidence there's plenty
of evidence in the record from which the
jury could infer those moving on your
honor to the independent contractor the
Court's already rejected this argument
ruled that an attorney any client have a
principal agent relationship and as your
honor said on Friday there's no evidence
in this case of anything otherwise as to
this argument that the counterclaim
statements or statements of opinion the
court has already found twice that they
are not statements of opinion both on
January 4th 2021 in its opinion letter
denying Mr Depp's demur as to the
counter claim statements and at the
motion for summary judgment Hearing in
March of this year as the anti-slap
argument the court again has already
ruled at the March 24th
2021
opinion that the statements are as a
matter of law regarding matters of
public opinion the court has already
ruled that therefore the only remaining
issue for anti-slap is whether the
intent element of immunity is met be as
we discussed on Friday the intent
element of immunity is substantially the
same as the actual malice standard which
the evidence in this case
easily allows the jury to uh to find in
favor of misheard on that I won't go
through the uh the Litany of evidence
that supports that Mr Depp is an abuser
here but I'll touch on a few things that
relate to Mr Chu's argument one Mr Chew
was totally misrepresenting uh Mr
Doherty's testimony there's not a single
piece of evidence your honor in this
case suggesting that misheard and the
ACLU Were Somehow conspiring to achieve
a defamatory implication to Mr Depp
that's simply not what Mr Doherty said
Mr Chu's feel free to argue that to the
jury but that's not what his testimony
reflects your honor there's also
plenty of evidence that's been educed
both in Mr Depp's claim and in Miss
Hertz counterclaim that show that
absolutely there was that the
counterclaim statements are 100 false
there was no hoax perpetrated Mr Depp is
an abuser who abused misheard she did
not conspire with her friends to create
a hoax she did not create a hoax herself
and just very briefly
some of the evidence that's come up
since the last motion to strike your
honor that Mr Chu conveniently
disregards in this brief or the
testimony of Rocky Pennington the
testimony of Josh drew the testimony of
Elizabeth Mars all of whom completely
corroborate Miss heard's account of the
events of May 21st 2016. the testimony
of Melanie Iglesias who testified that
she covered misheard uh Miss herbs
Bruises with makeup on right after the
December 15th incident that provided
ample testimony to support that misheard
often would cover her bruises that were
caused by the plaintiff in this case by
Mr Depp with makeup he ignores the
evidence of Christy Sexton he ignores
the evidence of Iota right he ignores
the evidence of Whitney Enriquez all of
these Witnesses and others have
testified extensively about Mr Depp's
abusive Behavior toward misheard
physical abuse emotional abuse
psychological abuse verbal abuse your
honor Mr Depp's own writings recordings
pictures and videos confirm that the
list goes on there's abundant evidence
in the record your honor from which the
jury could and again we believe will
find that misheard is not liable for
defamation to Mr death and therefore by
definition she is she has not acted with
actual malice and based on the Court's
rulings on March 21st 24th 2021 she
would be entitled to anti-slap immunity
which would permit permit her to ask the
court to award attorneys fees against Mr
up so with that your honor I'm happy to
answer any questions the court has
that's fine thank you sir thank you yes
sir
writer I will be brief in deference to
the Court's time and the jury's time
what Mr rottenborn said about
Mr waldman's allegedly going to the LAPD
about perjury is a complete non-sequitur
if they thought that that Were Somehow
improper conduct
they could have included it in their
their counter claims they included
everything else but the kitchen sink and
most of it was thrown out there was
nothing in there about Mr Waldman going
to the LAPD so that is a very clear
non-sequitur red herring distraction
number two when your honor ruled on
summary judgment on the issue of the
counter claims your honor was dealing
with a different standard and a
different evidentiary record at that
time Mr Waldman had not testified which
is material Mr Waldman has now testified
for purposes of trial we have his trial
testimony it's very clear that he did
not act with actual malice they didn't
even argue that
so that's pretty clear
and again
this is consistent the third point is
that it's it's all about games they
didn't sue Mr Waldman on the three
statements
they didn't try to fill the hole they've
been telling us for a week that they're
going to call Mr Depp to try to fill the
hole and their counter claims they
didn't do that
and it's very consistent with the game
playing
let's go into court after the police
have found no problem
and after witness after witness who had
no relationship with each other said
there are no visible marks
let's not give Mr Depp's lawyer the
required 24-hour notice before
the tro let's March into court with our
publicist with our lawyer with our best
friend who no longer talks to her let's
get a tro
and when the metoo folks say why are you
taking seven million dollars from an
abuser they said I didn't take money
from the abuser I gave it all to charity
well they didn't I I don't think anybody
should feel bad about them stiffing the
ACLU given what the ACLU did in this
case which is a monstrosity
but she did stiff the sick and dying
children it is gamesmanship and and
that's what she's doing here today but
the law is the law and they have not
fulfilled their burden with respect to
the counter claims there is virtually no
Nexus between Mr Depp and Mr Waldman as
to these statements at issue except for
the fact that he is an attorney and that
is not sufficient in a case where they
have not even established that Mr Depp
was aware of these statements and they
knew that they couldn't do it and they
didn't even try and it's more of
the gamesmanship
when
misheard plays word games with Mr Depp
about oh I didn't punch you Johnny I
just hit you imagine if the shoe were on
the other foot and Mr Depp a man was
saying to a woman oh woman up I only hit
you I didn't punch you and when she it
was chilling when she warned him on the
tape you go tell a judge you go tell a
jury that you a man were abused see if
they're going to believe that
it is an abuse of the system uh and
she's done it throughout finally your
honor and Mr rottenborn makes an
excellent point with which I agree
which was that with respect to each of
the three statements Mr Waldman was
clearly identified even by the Tabloid
that printed these well within
articles that had both sides represented
that he was Mr Walden's attorney even
the reader of a tabloid understands that
when you're getting statements from
attorneys it's going to be forwarding
their clients point of view Mr Waldman
is not the only attorney who has spoken
out Robbie Kaplan who was
Miss hurt second attorney so miss heard
started out with Eric George he made
comments to the Press objection your
honor again this is so much further
beyond what your honor is addressing I'm
finishing up okay I'm finishing up my
point your honor and it's on point is
that Mr George made statements
supporting Miss heard's position
Ms Kaplan made very clear statements uh
supporting her client's position on the
Merricks and so did Mr Waldman but
everybody knows when reading knows that
those are statements bipartisan so for
the reasons that we've stated and the
reason set forth in the brief we
respectfully submit
that the court should Grant the motion
to strike or in light of the fact that
Mr Depp May reappear at the very least
take these motions under advisement
until the close of all evidence thank
you all right thank you sir all right in
this matter I've reviewed all the
defendant's evidence as to her
counterclaim and I've considered the
arguments of Her counsel in plaintiff's
council first to address a few issues
that I believe are outside the motion to
strike and that says to the slap defense
the slap defense is just that it's a
defense so it's really not considered an
emotion to strike having said that we we
went down that legal Road on Friday as
far as the slap defense goes as far as
the jury instructions in this particular
case if the plaintiff prevails it must
be with actual malice therefore if it's
with actual malice immunity does not
apply under that statute so we will deal
with that with jury instructions that we
have as to independent uh contractor
again I think it's outside the motion to
strike however Mr Waldman was
plaintiff's attorney since 2016 before
the initiation of litigation there is
evidence that Mr Waldman had a certain
role during the prior divorce
proceedings in the UK case additionally
there is evidence that shows his legal
representation was broader than just a
limited litigation as outlined in all
the cases presenting an attorney as an
independent contractor
so the only evidence in this case to
this point is that Mr Waldman was an
agent to Mr Depp and that is the basis
to weigh the motion to strike as far as
the opinions argument again I think that
is outside the motion to strike the
opinions argument the court has already
ruled on this matter as to the three
statements that are issued in the
counterclaim ruled that they were not
opinion at the demurrent at summary
judgment so that argument
will not be part of the motion to strike
so when assessing a motion to strike the
court accepts the favorable evidence
induced as true towards the non-moving
party the court cannot reject any
inference from the evidence favorable to
the non-moving party unless it would
defy logic and common sense when there
is any doubt in question the court
should overrule a motion to strike
agency may be inferred from the conduct
of the parties and from surrounding
facts and circumstances when there is no
direct evidence circumstances May and
usually are relied upon to determine
whether an agency relationship exists a
principle is liable for the tortious
acts of his agent if the agent was
performing his principle business and
acting within the scope of his agency if
an agent's torches act arises from their
agency relationship is enacted in part
to serve as the principal the principal
can be held liable for the tort here the
alleged tort is defamation
besides demonstrating the agency
relationship the defendant must prove Mr
Waldman published an actionable
statement meaning a statement that is
both false and defamatory with the
requisite intent as to agency Mr Walden
was plaintiff's attorney at the time of
the alleged defamatory statements were
made Mr Walden does not deny this and
neither does the plaintiff moreover Mr
Waldman made the allegedly defamatory
statements about the defendant during
the proceedings of this action and
interacted with the defendant once the
statements were made while still
representing the plaintiff taking the
surrounding circumstances as a whole an
agency relationship can be inferred and
thus thus a scintilla of evidence
regarding agency must be turned over to
the jury in addition the jury May infer
that Mr Waldman made these specific
statements to a third party to service
plaintiff by portraying defendant as an
opposing litigant in a negative light
it is not disputed that Mr Waldman
published statements and that there is a
question there is a question as to
whether statements are false and both
parties disagree and have presented
conflicting evidence as such as to
actual malice Mr Waldman made the
counter claim statements after he met
with his client in addition there's
evidence the plaintiff was with Mr
Waldman at a meeting in February 2020
with a daily mail online further
defendant claimed that she met with Mr
Waldman where he threw the paper
containing the counterclaim statements
within them consequently there is more
than a evidence that a reasonable juror
May infer Mr Waldman made the
counterclaim statements while realizing
they were false or with a reckless
disregard for their truth it is not my
role to measure the veracity or weight
of the evidence the fourth circuit the
Virginia Supreme Court have made it
crystal clear that actual malice is a
question for the fact finder so
therefore the plaintiff's motion strike
is denied okay
thank you is there any other preliminary
matters before the jury
okay
foreign
all right are we ready for the jury then
okay
foreign
foreign
good morning ladies and gentlemen I
apologize we have a few housekeeping
matters to take care of but thank you we
have your seat all right your next
witness your honor on behalf of
defendant and counterclaiman Amber Heard
we rest all right thank you all right
rebuttal evidence yes uh your honor Mr
Depp calls Walter Hamada of Warner
Brothers all right Mr Hamad
foreign
just to clarify this is by depositions
so we may need that okay okay I
apologize I should have provided notice
that's all right thank you
[Music]
foreign
what do you work for our Warner Brothers
entertainment pink
yes I do in what capacity my title is
president of dc-based film productions
for Warner Brothers
what if anything you did to prepare to
testify for Warner Brothers as two
topics 2 through 18.
um I did not do anything to prepare for
this
other than my meeting that I had with
the attorneys
did Warner Brothers have a contract with
Amber Heard
to perform in Aquaman too
yes there was a they we had we had an
option agreement for her for Augmentin
do you know what it is
that looks like a standard contract
between a a an actor and in the studio
and which actor was involved in this
which which actor was a party to this
contract
for the for the role of Mara in Aquaman
and it sequels which studio contracted
with uh Amber Heard
Warner Brothers
when did you uh come to be the president
of DC at the beginning of 2018 2018.
Mr habata
was
misheard ever released by Warner
Brothers
from
the Aquaman 2 contract or the what you
call the option agreement no
was she released from her Aquaman 2
contract honor about February 22 2021.
uh no
was Miss heard ever rehired for Aquaman
to
buy Warner Brothers no
did Miss heard receive a pay increase
for Aquaman 2.
why not
so we it as a rule
as a company we make these we go through
a lot of trouble when we make our deals
with our actors we get option
uh we get options on them for subsequent
movies and I think traditionally I'm
prior to me joining the company every
option was renegotiated and one of the
things that we were trying to put a
reign in on was not renegotiating every
deal with the understanding that people
come in and make these deals and they
have an understanding that there will be
options and that there's a deal in place
and there was a big part of our
philosophy that we were going to hold
people to their options moving forward
but did Warner Brothers at any point in
time
reduce
heard's role
in Aquaman 2.
the role in the film that besides the
role of the film that she has was
determined in the early development of
the script which would have happened
in 2018 I would say
and from there to Beyond normal
development the role sort of
the characters involvement in the story
was sort of what it was from the
beginning
was her role ever reduced for any reason
um no I mean again from the early stages
of the development of the script uh the
movie was built around uh the character
of Arthur and the character form Arthur
Dean Jason Momoa and Orem being Patrick
Wilson
so they were always the two
co-leads of the movie did Warner
Brothers ever plan to portray Miss heard
as the co-league in Aquaman 2.
it was the movie was always pitched as a
buddy comedy between uh Jason Momoa and
Patrick Wilson
was misheard cast in Aquaman
yes she was
was Miss heard cast in Aquaman too
yes she was
Miss heard paid for her services in
Aquaman one
yes was misheard paid for her services
in Aquaman too
yes
was her compensation for Aquaman too
affected in any way by anything said by
Johnny Depp
no
well her compensation for Aquaman
to
affected by anything said by Adam
Waldman
no
was her compensation for Aquaman 2
affected by anything said by anybody
representing Johnny Depp
no
was there any delay
in Warner Brothers exercising the option
to cast misheard in Aquaman too yes
there was
how long a delay was there
um
I don't know probably weeks
what was the cause of the delay
conversations about potentially
recasting
was the producer Peter saffron
who was the director
uh James won
good Warner Brothers believe that those
concerns were legitimate
uh yeah I mean I had no reason not to
believe the director and producer of the
movie
and you are testifying today the
representative of more correct
yes I am what if any creative concerns
did Warner Brothers have
about asking
Amber Heard as Mira in Aquaman too
what is the concerns that were brought
up at the wrap of the first movie
production first movie which is the
issue of chemistry did the two have
chemistry
um you know I think editorially they
were able to to make that relationship
work in the first movie but there was a
concern that it took a lot of effort to
get there and would we be better off
recasting finding someone who had had a
more natural chemistry with phmomoa and
move forward that one
he had Warner Brothers uh take any steps
affirmatively to
audition other
actresses for the role of Mira in
Aquaman too
no we did not
other than the creative concerns and
concerns about chemistry you've
testified about
was there any other reason
Warner Brother is delayed in picking up
Miss Herbert's option more Aquaman too
no it was all it was all concerns about
whether she was the right bit of casting
for the movie
what role if any
did
misheard's dispute with Johnny Depp
have in Warner Brothers the lay picking
and picking up Miss heard option for
Aquaman too there was there was none
from orend
in time
was Warner Brothers considering
pain misheard more money for Aquaman 2
than to set forth in the option contract
you previously identified
no as I said we were we were determined
to hold our actors interopted agreements
what Warner Brothers have paid misheard
more money on Aquaman too
if it had picked up her option earlier
no
at any time from the beginning of
History through today
did Warner Brothers ever release
misheard
from the Aquaman 2 contract
no
any point in time from the beginning of
History to today
did Warner Brothers
rehire Ms heard for Aquaman 2.
no because we just picked up our option
and when is the last time you spoke with
Rob Cohen
relating in any
one no it would have been the same time
that I was having those conversations
with Peter saffron
[Music]
no
I've not had any conversations with
Zacks later to speak at all with Jason
Momoa
in preparation for your
deposition today
have you ever spoken with Jason Momoa
about any issues relating to chemistry
he and our first
um yes
when did you speak with Jason Momoa
about chemistry issues between he and
billboard
it would have been in that same time
period where we were prior to Green
Light of the movie
now
you were asked some questions about
Scripts
did you review any of the drafts from
the script for Aquaman 2. yes
when I I part of my role was hold your
ass to the scripts as they come in when
was the first script for Aquaman 2
[Music]
I cannot tell you probably in 2018
latter part of 2018 would be my guess
and how many versions of the script have
been written by the beginning of 2021
for Aquaman 2.
oh there were probably
half dozen drafts of the script
what if anything did Rob Cowan say to
you about chemistry What specifically
about the chemistry between Amber Heard
and Jason Momoa
just the the fact that they didn't
really have a lot of chemistry together
you know the reality is
it's not uncommon on movies for for two
leads to not have chemistry and that
it's sort of movie Magic and editorial
the ability to sort of put performances
together and with the magic of you know
a great score and and how you put the
pieces together you can you can
fabricate sort of that chemistry
um and so I think in in at the end of
the day I think if you watch the movie
they look like they had great chemistry
but I just know that through the course
of the post-production that it took a
lot of effort to get there sometimes you
don't sometimes it's very easy you just
put the you know characters on the
screen together and they work and
sometimes it's harder and so can you
give me anything more specific about
what it was with Amber Heard and Jason
Momoa that was difficult for the
chemistry now because it's it's it's
it's like what makes a movie star a
movie star like you you know it when you
see it and the chemistry wasn't there
no you've used the term fabricated a
number of times what did you do to
fabricate the chemistry between Amber
Heard and Jason Momoa
well those are just it's editorial
they're a good editor and a good
filmmaker can pick the right takes can
pick the right moments and put scenes
together again score is a big you know
the music in the scene makes a big
difference it can make a happy
better or sad thing so happier uh and so
it was sort of the it's it's it's just
the magic of post-production
editing sound sound design music Etc
what do you mean by fabricating though I
mean were they literally
falsifying or were they just picking the
best music let's just finish my question
were they picking the best music and
picking the best looks because that's
their job and that's what you do on
everything
but that is what we do in
post-correction that's what filmmakers
do and no yeah they they they this is on
any production you're doing that you're
you're putting performances together
sometimes it's even easier than others
uh this one uh was more difficult
um because of the lack of Chemistry
Between between the two
um but they were able to James one and
the editor were able to get it to a
place where the end result actually
works and it's great
in fact that's the job of every
filmmaker right is to put all those
combinations together to make the most
successful production absolutely what
has been marked as exhibit number five
it's
alh18247 and this is a text message
exchange between James Juan and Amber
Heard and you mentioned James Wan was
the director of Aquaman 2 is that
correct and Aquaman the first one
correct correct
and uh James is texting to Amber on
August 25 2018 you rated really high
with the audience exclamation work
exclamation mark you see that yes this
is August 25
2018. what's going on on August 25 2018
that would cause the director to send a
text message to Amber I'm going to be a
test screening we so during our
post-production movie we
test the movie with an audience and the
audience tells us what they liked and
what they didn't like and so that's what
he's referring to there and they really
liked Amber Heard correct yes she did
she tested well you hit billion dollars
is that correct
and more specifically did you play any
role in the determination to communicate
to Amber's Representatives that Warner
Brothers was considering not exercising
or option
um yeah probably in the sense of we had
the conversations and I believe I recall
we had uh that's where Peter saffron
offered to reach out to the agent and
express which direction we're leaning
have you seen any document
chemistry issues between Amber Heard and
Jason Momoa in Aquaman one documents no
I mean those were all conversations but
if Jason came back and James Juan came
back you were guaranteed that Amber
Heard the Play Mirror correct
that's correct
and Jason Momoa
was able to negotiate a different
a different compensation structure was
he not for Aquaman too that's true he
didn't he did renegotiate
[Music]
what if any issues did you have with
Amber Heard in Aquaman too
uh my understanding is actually the
production went very smoothly
thank you your next Witness
your daughter we call uh Dr Colburn next
but I know we have a preliminary matter
that we need to deal with greatly if we
approach sure
all right ladies and gentlemen I
apologize again we have a few things
take care of we're just gonna go ahead
and take our morning recess now for 15
minutes do not discuss the case and do
not talk to anybody okay
do not do any outside research sorry
that was the same thing
all right and if the doctor testifies
then is that WebEx okay so I'll get that
set up too while we take the break as
well all right all right we'll go ahead
and take a break let's make it 10 50 to
give them time to look at everything
okay
all right
beautiful all right yes sir okay
I'm smarter
all right yes you ready for the jury
yes okay
sir can you hear me
yes can you count to five for me
one two three four five
all right I'm just trying to get you on
big screen we're waiting for the jury
just give us a minute okay sir
thank you
think you can be seated all right your
next witness we called Dr Colbert all
right sir if you could raise your right
hand
do you swear for him tell truth under
penalty of law
yes your honor I would just object that
Dr Culver appears to have a sack of
documents right in front of him all
right you sure you can put your hand
down and any documents you have if you
could put them away and just testify
from your memory okay sir
thank you thank you all right your
question good morning Dr Culver
morning could you please State your full
name for the record
David Allen Colbert and what is your
profession
I'm a plastic and hand surgeon and how
long have you been a plastic enhanced
surgeon
been in practice for 26 years
where do you currently work
at Cedars-Sinai Medical Center how long
have you worked there
for the past 26 years
do you know the plaintiff in this action
Johnny Depp
I do
and how do you know Mr Depp
are you taking care of him when he'd
entered his hand
when did Mr debt become your patient
sometime in March of 2015.
and what type of treatment did you
provide to Mr Depp
fracture of his finger with soft tissue
loss and so I'm reconstructed his finger
when did you perform perform the first
surgery on Mr Duck's finger
I believe it was around March 20th of
2015.
and what was involved in that surgery
just briefly
the breathing The Divided life's tissue
including a
hypothene or skin graft
store some of the soft tissue wasps that
he had and then also putting a pin in
because he had a displaced distal
Phalanx fracture
what was the state of Mr Depp's hand
immediately after that surgery
I'm sorry I think the audio cut out a
little bit could you please repeat your
answer
it was injured and that stopped to she
lost and the fraction of his distal
phalans
and what type of cast was on Mr Depp's
hand after you performed that surgery
it was a plaster splint
and can you please describe to the jury
what what a plaster splint would look
like
so it's it's like a cast but you don't
want to put everything circumferential
on it because of swelling after surgery
so I believe in Mr Depp's case it was
like the two fingers I think the third
finger was the one that was operated
onto these two fingers the third and
fourth finger together and it's a splint
with plaster on the top and on the
bottom that goes around the hand uh to
protect it
how mobile was Mr Depp's hand when it
was in that cast
well you couldn't move his third and
fourth fingers because of the bulkiness
of the splint typically post-operatively
it's a more bulkier splint right after
the surgery so it's
uh
not very um
it gets in the way
could Mr debb grab someone with that
cast on his hand
mm-hmm
I could I could attempt to grab someone
I don't know how successful he would be
he had his index finger free and his
thumb free but other fingers were
um probably not being able to move
how long was the pin in Mr Depp's finger
I thought 11 or 12 days
and how was the pin removed
it was removed under local anesthesia in
my office
how long did you ultimately treat Mr
Depp for his hand injury
for several months
and why was that
it was
a
required a few more little office
procedures to clean up the tissue we had
an infection
as a result of the injury so we had to
be on antibiotics for some time until it
finally completely healed do you recall
when the infection developed
it was a few weeks after the surgery and
that's when I took out the pen
when was the last time that you saw Mr
duck
sometime in 2015
I don't recall when and when was the
last time that you spoke to Mr debt
of 2015. okay
thank you Dr Colburn all right
cross-examination
foreign
so you said that this plaster splint was
put on on after surgery on March 20th
2015.
yes and a plaster
a plaster splint is that sometimes
called half a cast
sometimes it's called half a cast or a
soft cast
something like that yeah and it's it's
made of plaster of Paris right
correct and plaster of Paris hardens
like a cast does correct
so other than the fact that it's a
little smaller than a cast that goes
around your whole hand it's just as hard
as a cast that would be put on a broken
arm or a broken hand correct
well it's softer on the side so the
fingers can expand through swelling so
it's not fully the plaster appears
circumferential around everything so
there are areas that are softer allow
for swelling but the parts that are
covered with plaster of Paris are just
as hard as any other cast correct
correct
and regardless of whether Mr Depp could
have grabbed someone with the hand with
the cast on he he could have grabbed
someone with a hand without the cast on
correct
correct Michelle can you pull up exhibit
400 please this has been admitted your
honor all right
permission to publish yes yes sir
uh Dr Culver I'm just going to ask
um Michelle here to just scroll through
these pictures and I'd ask you to take a
look at them
your honor I'm going to object for lack
of foundation for these photographs
they're already in evidence
I with respect to the questions to the
witness thank you Michelle if you could
go back up to that stop right there
is there anything about the cast that
was put on Mr Debb's hand on March 20th
2015 that would have prevented him from
doing this damage to miss heard's closet
on March 23rd 2015. objection calls for
speculation overruled
I mean he had his other hand available
so no further questions thank you all
right redirect
Dr colber how many fingers were in the
plaster portion of the of Mr Depp's cast
two or three at least two were and the
third one and the fourth one
and why why did you call it a soft cast
because it's not fully posture doesn't
go around the entire uh hand because you
allow for swelling so there's plaster to
protect the
fracture so there's a little plaster on
it but it's on the top and the bottom
but it's not completely circumferential
so there's soft spots to it
and and where are those soft spots
located again
usually we'd put a piece of plaster
underneath the fingers and on top and
then the sides of the fingers it's soft
so that the fingers can swell after the
surgery could Mr Depp have hit someone
with the hand that had the cast on it
you could have hit someone with it
probably would have
um
injured damage to the cast
did you ever notice any damage to Mr
Depp's cast when you treated him
after the surgery
I don't recall
that's not not looking at times
could Mr Depp form a fist with the cast
on
no
no further questions thank you Dr Kohler
all right thank you sir that completes
your testimony thank you
your next Witness
plaintiff calls Richard Marx your honor
all right Master marks
sorry
just give us a second of the TV sir
you've already just reminded you're
still under oath okay sir
foreign
foreign
yes ma'am thank you
welcome back Mr Marks
um you've testified in this case
previously but would you just um briefly
remind the jury Who You Are
I'm Richard Marks and I'm a full-time
entertainment transactional attorney I
make deals uh every day for Productions
and for individuals I'm in the trenches
negotiating and then making sure the
contracts reflect the deals
um
and I'm very much distinguished from uh
the other side's expert who is not an
attorney who's not in the trenches
making deals is not in that day-to-day
process
Ed are you familiar with the testimony
of Catherine Arnold in this matter
yes
Analyze That testimony and provide
opinions in response yes
and generally what are those opinions
well my my opinions are that
she's very uh slick and smooth uh but
she's not an expert in Deal making uh
her assessment of damages
built on nothing and it's wildly
speculative
are you familiar with Ms Arnold's
opinion
fee for a subsequent picture option in a
multi-pixer contract when a film is
successful
yes I heard that opinion and are you
also familiar with her testimony that
under those circumstances an actor Will
renegotiate a 50 to 100 percent increase
in their salary for the next optional
film yes I heard her say that do you
agree with those opinions absolutely not
why not sir
well what we're dealing with in this
case is a test option agreement and
that's an agreement uh it's a
multi-picture agreement and it's the
nightmare for people like me you the
test is going to take place let's say
for 10 actors the next morning at nine
and you have to fully negotiate a
contract that might cover four movies
and have it signed before they're
allowed to test so that if they're
chosen for the part we have the full
contract there's no renegotiation
so you've got a contract for a
multi-picture deal it's usually a
franchise
and
you negotiate the first movie and
normally if they get the part they're
the chosen one uh they're the stars-born
moment if you will uh they get the part
normally their salary is
inflated from their normal salary
because now they're going to play a
character that could go on for four
movies
in this case Miss hurt's first salary
when she got the part was 450 000
dollars
if Warner Brothers and DC Comics decided
to make a next movie
um
they could recast her they had no
obligation all they had was an option
but if they did Caster up front that
they had agreed to more than doubled her
salary like two and a quarter times to
get to the million dollars
uh these are large uh bumps if you will
there if an actor is on a series say
they go and they have five options they
go up in increments of five percent ten
percent twenty percent not these
multiples that you see in uh a test
option agreement and that's one of the
reasons that uh they aren't renegotiated
normally they are in some instances but
not normally
significance of the test part in a test
option agreement
the test significance is that
an established actor usually wouldn't
test they'd be offered the role
the misheard was in a group of actors
that read it needed to be tested to see
if the studio wanted to hire them and
then if they hired them they would be
locked up for potentially for movies at
very lucrative increases because out
after Aquaman one she gets to a million
dollars Aquaman two she gets to two
million dollars and Aquaman four
uh three excuse me you get to four
million dollars these are unheard of
bumps if you're going on a normal career
and trying to increase your salary by
increments
in your experience what is customary for
negotiations of multi-picture deals
uh
well I think what happened in this case
was customary for negotiation of
multi-picture deals
um
and by that I mean that
you assume success the reason you go
from the first Justice League movie
where uh Miss heard played mirror the
first time the reason you more than
double her salary is you assume success
so you've already built in
the bonus that Miss Arnold was referring
to a renegotiation if you will for the
third movie instead of doubling her
salary Miss Arnold said it would only be
fair to quadruple her salary
and that's just not the way these
idiosyncratic contracts work they're a
very small portion of the contracts we
deal with
Ms Arnold's opinion that misheard salary
for Aquaman 2 could have been
renegotiated to around four million
dollars I am do you agree with that
opinion no why not
well as I've said that would now be
after a healthy First payday
it's more than doubled and now it would
be quadrupled that's not the way it
happens
um
Walter Hamada who is the president of
the that part of the studio said it
doesn't happen they're not going to do
it
um
Miss Arnold for some substance says well
Jason Momoa got to do it but she doesn't
give us any of the details we know that
Jason Momoa was in a movie uh before
the Justice League he played Aquaman in
a movie not office not with Miss Mira in
that movie so he had a history before
the first movie with Amber Heard he
played Aquaman we don't know what his
contract the state of it was when you
got to Aquaman 2 and she says
unsupported that he renegotiated we're
not sure what he renegotiated to
but I can say that at the end of the
option period when you've only got one
option left
and you want that star in more movies
uh you may renegotiate but it's not a a
gratuity it's we'll give you more for
the last option if you'll give us three
more options
uh it's a give and take and
unfortunately Miss Arnold didn't give us
any of that background or those building
blocks and then I think yesterday she
said and the other actors renegotiated
and again we don't know their salary
history we don't know their contracts
we don't know anything except she's
asking you just to believe her as what I
refer to as a professional expert
are you aware that Ms Arnold's opined
that but for the alleged inflammatory
statements by Mr Waldman misheard would
have heard 45 million in the last 18
months and then the next three to five
years yes I am
um I'd like to address some of the
components of that one by one with you
Mr Marks are you familiar with her
testimony that misheard would continue
to make films for approximately four
million dollars each following Aquaman
2. yes do you agree with that testimony
no why not
well again
in Aquaman 2
uh Amber Heard has already had this huge
increase she worked on Aquaman 2 for 2
million
what uh Miss Arnold is saying is oh she
should have worked on it for 4 million
uh which I disagree with and I I don't I
think there's there is reasons to
negotiate they weren't here in this case
show the 4 million I have a disagreement
with but even if it was at 4 million or
if it was a 2 million
the the four or five movies
that uh misheard might get might be
independent movies they may might be
Standalone Studio movies they might be
passion projects every actor has has
a quiver full of quotes and their
highest quote is for the superhero
um
fantasy a journey
their lowest quote might be for the
independent passion project where
they'll they'll defer their salary and
almost take nothing to work just sag
minimum uh and uh
to assume that she'd get four or five
more movies at this her last fantasy
quote would be to assume that those are
also those type of movies playing
another character
and
I
Miss Arnold says that that Miss heard's
breakout moment her Star is Born moment
is Christmas 2018.
if that's true and I don't think it's
true those moments know don't normally
happen to Supporting Cast but if it's
true
as a deal maker you would expect if you
represent a producers production
companies to flock in to take advantage
of this hot
star and to sign them up and we have
from Christmas 2018 to Spring 20 where
there there is none of this activity
the the stars-born phenomena didn't
happen uh misheard starred in one series
of Eight Episodes and she earned a
healthy fee two hundred thousand dollars
an episode
but that's five times less than the
million uh Miss Arnold is tossing out
supposedly based on Jason momoa's quote
she doesn't prove it or give us facts
and
Jason Momoa is not a comparable actor
he's been in a series where they shot 78
episodes 44 episodes 21 episodes he
played Conan the Barbarian he was in
Game of Thrones
all right I'll see the objection next
question Mr Rex we'll get to some of
those um issues in a moment but um I
want to take you back for a second I
believe he testified a few minutes ago
that
um your understanding is that the last
option in a multi-picture deal might be
renegotiated under some circumstances
do you have an understanding of whether
um Aquaman 2 was the last option in Ms
herd's contract with Warner Brothers oh
no no uh Aquaman 2 has not even been
released and Warner Brothers has a
fourth option for Aquaman 3 or another
movie where Mira appears that character
and they've agreed to double the salary
again
so it's in success and that assumes that
they recast and that they make the movie
are you aware of Ms Arnold's testimony
that misheard would have made several
million dollars on endorsement deals
such as the one she had with L'Oreal
aware of that testimony do you agree
with that opinion no why not
again this is a business of
personalities uh
we didn't after the breakout moment that
Miss Arnold talked about Christmas 2018
we didn't see endorsement deals flocking
to uh misheard
uh during that 16-month period before
Adam Waldman made a few statements in uh
the London Daily Mail I believe it was
we didn't see those endorsements coming
to her we didn't uh
what Ms Arnold shows you is these
non-comparable actors they had
endorsement deals
but she doesn't show you
when she describes the breakout moment
and why she's comparing Amber Heard to
these what I call uncomparable actors
but she's making the comparison she's
saying well they had all these deals why
wouldn't you shave
but for the statements that happen 16
months later
and I guess my primary question is what
happened in the 16 months even if you
believe
three statements in the Daily Mail are
the state through the heart of this uh
stars-born moment
thinking about Ms Arnold's testimony
that misheard would have made one
million dollars an episode and a couple
of streaming series following her A Star
is Born moment yes I I heard it I have
an opinion what's your opinion
well
after Aquaman one this is a major coup
Amber Heard got that role she tested for
it she could have been the other 19
actresses or 10 or whoever else tested
didn't get it she got the role and she
got her salary uh doubled for Aquaman
one to a million dollars
now
Miss Arnold wants you to believe that
that million dollars would translate
into should get that for each episode of
the series
we know what you got for a series she
got a serious uh in that period after
Christmas 2018 before uh spring of uh
2020 she got a series it was eight
episodes and it was two hundred thousand
dollars an episode and Miss Arnold is
from somewhere in in a glib way saying
she got a couple series and a million
each and I can tell you is it someone in
the trenches
rarely rarely does an actor get a
million dollars for a serious episode
uh and
um and again in those 16 months there
were no offers for series at a million
dollars an episode in fact her only
series is the 200 000 and if you look at
her resume
the series that misheard we're in I
think the longest one ran Eight Episodes
Jason momola if you were to believe
um Miss Arnold and somehow Jason momoa's
agent wrote their confidentiality in the
agreement and he had a series at a
million dollars an episode if you're to
believe that Jason Momoa has had a
series with 78 episodes with 44 episodes
with 21 episodes with 18 episodes with
21 episodes he was a
again there's not a comparableness there
we spoke a few minutes
part of that agreement
the option part of the agreement uh
gives
the employer the studio the option
they don't have to do anything
they have an option to either employ you
at a very healthy salary to play this
role or not they can recast the
superhero role you just have to think of
how many actors have played Batman or
Superman they they can do what they want
and indeed
since there's no contract they only have
a choice to exercise their option or not
they might say we're not exercising
unless you reduce your compensation who
knows what the negotiation would be but
it's not a contract until the studio
exercises the option and they don't have
to
alternative to an option agreement
well the alternative is most agreements
in Hollywood you're hired to play the
role
uh
or once you exercise the option then
it becomes for that picture an agreement
like others in Hollywood you are now
hired to play that role so
most contracts are guaranteed you're
hired to play the role in an option
agreement once they exercise the option
for that movie it becomes a guaranteed
contract
are you aware that Ms Arnold testified
that misheard was released from her
Aquaman 2 contract and then subsequently
rehired
I heard that testimony is that
consistent with your experience of the
film in
film into contracts
again
Studios don't do things they don't have
to do
as we heard Mr Hamada the president of
the studio say uh you either exercise
your option or you don't
they exercise their option
he denied
releasing and then rehiring and in my
experience
in almost five decades in the business
doing this type of work not talking
about it not Consulting I mean I have
you know I
I heard Miss Arnold say she'd been an
expert 100 times that's I'm a
transactional lawyer I do this
occasionally basically
um
uh you know it's it's not a contract
till the uh option it and and they they
pick up their option and at that point
it's guaranteed contract and then
different
different rules apply to it
in your experience in the industry do
Studios typically comment on those types
of actions that they're taking with
respect to options
no uh just like Mr Hamada said they
don't need to comment on it they either
exercise the option or they don't in
Hollywood silence is the default uh you
play no card before it's time
and and the cards there were exercise
the option or not and I was surprised by
Mr Hamada under oath basically saying
that there was this discussion of
chemistry that objection your honor
hearsay
I think it was um it was an in court
statement this morning I believe your
honor
all right
that you were
it's here say like yesterday
I mean it's hearsay
I'll rule rejection go ahead thank you I
didn't hear it go ahead sure
overalls you can continue
I'm surprised to hear Mr modest say that
they they talked about uh chemistry that
would normally be behind closed doors uh
because it can't help your relationship
with the actor you're either gonna
exercise or not and
um that was
quite a bit of Candor from someone at
his level
and so therefore I I uh uh take it at
face value I I think he felt that he was
under oath and he was telling the truth
but it wouldn't judge
I'll sustain the objection
um Mr Marks are the circumstances where
a studio would be more likely to say
something about not using an actor again
in a franchise yes what are those
circumstances once they've exercised the
option once the contract is guaranteed
the studio still has the right to pay
the actor but not play them pay or play
them and that is a rare condition
because you've hired the actor you've
got to pay them but you say go home we
will we're recasting
in that situation
after you've exercised the option and
the contract is guaranteed if you
uh
pay off the actor that's normally
comment on that becomes a bit of
information because it's not normal
is that circumstance different from Ms
heard's contract with Warner Brothers
for the Aquaman movies oh yeah yeah Miss
Hertz contract again it was just an
option either we exercise it or we don't
and if we exercise it
she's in the film if we don't she's not
until we exercise it we have our right
to recast or not make the movie and even
after we exercise it we'd still have a
right to recast and not make the movie
we just have to pay her salary
do you understand that Ms Arnold
Compares Ms heard's career trajectory
with that of other actors including
Jason Momoa Gal Gadot Zendaya Anita
armas and Chris Pine
I heard that in what's your opinion of
those actors as comparables for misheard
uh
even miss heard's agent Jessica K said
that for those actors
and I believe the same response your
honor that it was in testimony it was
played in court earlier this week I mean
that's not what she testified to I mean
he's characterizing testimony that was
from days ago and I don't even think she
testified to that urine you can
cross-examine
overruled um you may continue again uh
they are not comparable
Jason Momoa was Aquaman uh Chris Pine
was Captain Kirk Gal Gadot was Wonder
Woman
Zendaya has been working on dising
channels since she was 13. she's in all
the Spider-Man movies she goes by one
name uh Anna De armas uh you know when
she was in uh a movie uh that they call
uh you know her breakout it was as a
nude poster she's been an ensemble piece
Knives Out These are not comparables
now
Miss Arnold stuck to Jason Momoa who's
the most non-comparable because of his
history and his career
but she didn't give us the advantage of
telling us what his contracts were
what he renegotiated to what he earned
she didn't give us any of those building
blocks she just created she set him up
as a comparable and then said what
misheard should earn but she never gave
us the salary of Jason Momoa or the
other comparables and is she built like
this house of cards on nothing uh you
know she showed us the the with her
words the beautiful clothing that the
emperor was wearing but but we could see
if you know the business the objection
your Honors that he wasn't beyond the
scope of the question all right also
seeing the objection next question okay
um you're just speaking about Mr Mamoa
as a comparable are you aware that Ms
Arnold's Compares miss her to Mr Mamoa
as an actor with equivalent franchise
experience who was able to renegotiate
his salary for significant increases in
bonus yes what's your response to that
opinion
again he didn't have comparable
franchise experience to to misheard
he was Conan the Barbarian he played
Aquaman in a movie that Amber Heard was
not in
he played Aquaman not a supporting
character like Mira it's just not
comparable
and you can say the words
but but I saw nothing from Miss Arnold
to back it up something to build on
which
if she was a negotiator in the trench
the the studio negotiator would say okay
so show us we have where's the cops
let's talk numbers because ultimately
that's what we have to get to not just
because you say it so we just don't
believe you you've got to show us
in your experience in the industry what
factors influence the negotiation of the
terms of a filament film agreement with
an actor
well
well I mean first it depends on the film
if the film is a million dollar movie
and everybody's deferring their salaries
that's one thing if it's a superhero
movie that's another
but for deal makers and negotiators
the best predictor of what the deal
should be is past earnings uh
precedent
cops you also look at the budget of the
movie what it can bear because if uh
Jason momoa's comp is 10 million dollars
but the budget's 10 million obviously he
has another price for that movie but the
best predictor of future earnings is
past earnings
and I didn't see any Miss Arnold talk
about past earnings at all except the
earnings in this rarified superhero four
picture deal where instead of
incremental increases which you normally
see
it was multiples increases and then when
you get on a series the big
renegotiation is was when the network
has no more options until then the
actors on the series get 5 10 15.
small percentage of raises they don't
get multiples they get the multiples if
it's success and the studio wants to
continue making the series and they want
to keep these characters that's when the
renegotiation happens
here even if we believe Miss Arnold
after Aquaman 2 there were still an
option waiting
at a big price so uh you know double the
previous payday
what's the significance of the timing of
the Waldman statements to the
opportunities Ms Arnold claims Ms heard
lost
well the argument is I understand it is
that uh Miss Arnold says that Miss heard
lost all these opportunities
because of they were that those losses
were caused by uh Adam waldman's
statements
16 months later
so I think the timing
sure
Mr Marks what's your overall assessment
of Ms Arnold's opinions in this case
My overall assessment of her opinions is
that they're not worth the paper they're
not written on
she knows something about our business
but not about negotiating deals
she may have uh gotten someone at the
more at the Endeavor office to uh breach
confidentiality but she never laid out
the building blocks Jefferson you have
to stop talking Mr Marx thank you
um be on the scope yeah Mr Marx can you
just limit your limit your testimony to
your opinion about um okay Arnold's
opinions please my opinion as someone
who's made deals
as a deal maker for almost 50 years is
that
she calls herself an expert but she's
not
she doesn't have the background she
doesn't have the day-to-day knowledge
and her testimony that I heard
did not back up her bottom line if you
want to get those figures you have to
show why they're deserved and again
it issues constructing a Django without
the bottom pieces it it does not hold up
under scrutiny by someone who makes
deals
no further questions all right
cross-examination
good morning Mr Marks
good morning
so you agree that Studios use comps to
negotiate
deals correct with actors
sometimes they do
and you have an issue with the comps
that um
Miss Arnold used correct
as you testified to I have an issue with
the comps that she says she used that
she didn't disclose
the comps being the actor is that you
just talked about she did this quote I
mean she disclosed the actors she
disclosed the actors and budget figures
from their movies she never disclosed
their salaries and salary history as
comps it you're not offering a different
set of comparators that should be used
correct I'm saying if you are going to
that's not my question are you offering
a different set of comparators than what
Miss Arnold used
I I'm I'm not uh here or offering uh
comparators I'm saying what she offered
that was my that was my question you're
not offering comparators correct no I
would say that was my comparison that
was my question can you motion to strike
after the oh all right we'll strike
after that just answer the questions Mr
Marks thank you yeah you're a deal
you're a deal maker correct
yes What actors have you negotiated for
in superhero movies
uh
well recently uh I've acted I've
negotiated for
um uh Chris Pratt in a superhero series
for Amazon I've negotiated a deal for uh
Michael Douglas not in a superhero movie
but a historical movie I've negotiated
recently a deal for Paul Rudd and Will
Ferrell on a on an Apple series
uh Billy crud up on an Apple series it
was a recent Talent deals What actors
have you negotiated for a superhero
movie
movie
um as I sit here now I can't remember a
superhero movie uh that I've uh
negotiated uh I've certainly negotiated
over my career
um
franchise movies and fantasy movies
so it's no you're having a good
negotiated with any for any actors for
superhero movies correct so you would
Define like um uh I don't know Jungle
Book isn't a superhero movie it's more
of a fantasy so so no correct okay so as
I sit here I can't think of a of a
Marvel type superhero movie that I've uh
negotiated
although I know there's one or two in
here now you testified and you agree
that Mr Mamoa negotiated his
multi-picture contract
for for Aquaman 2 correct
I heard uh Mr Hamada say there was a
renegotiation
uh but no facts were uh uh pro-offered
such as he didn't have an option uh his
options were out what he was earning and
what he renegotiated to and he is
Aquaman man so yes I did hear there was
a renegotiation and you understand that
his salary went from three to four
million to 15 million dollars
uh if you tell me that I haven't seen
this contract and I haven't heard any
testimony under oath uh that that's
where the leap was now myth hurts
contract did he get more did they get
more options
did they get more options this hurts
contract was a talent option contract
correct yes okay
um
and you agree that for the aqua if
there's an Aquaman 3 misheard would have
an option to receive four million
dollars correct for the movie well
actually you would language it Warner
Brothers would have the option to engage
her and if they engaged her she would
receive four million dollars correct
yeah she doesn't have the option to
refuse they have the option to engage
her and she would receive four million
dollars correct yes four million dollars
would you agree that the money Amber was
making on Aquaman two or three would be
her market rate for future Studio movies
I would think it would be her rate for
future Studio superhero movies uh but
not necessarily
Studio movies that aren't superheroes
that could be Standalone that could be
other type of Studio movies but for
super but for Studio superhero movies it
would be four million dollars correct if
I was uh Miss Hertz agent that's where I
would start okay
assuming everything was equal the budget
of the superhero movie that she was
in The Ensemble there's a lot of ifs to
look at but all things being equal you
agree that Aquaman was a breakthrough
role for Miss hurt wasn't it
uh it's it's the first movie of that ilk
that she makes but she is not Aquaman
she is Mira but it was a breakthrough
movie for miss her correct for her it's
a breakthrough movie to be in that film
and in The Ensemble absolutely
as she was the female star of that of
that movie correct I believe so
you would agree that for all of the
actors Miss Arnold listed as comparables
their career trajectory went up after
their breakthrough correct
she didn't give us the raw materials to
look at but I'll take your word that all
those unrelated actors in unrelated
films except for Jason Momoa there they
went up
and you're asked did Miss Arnold when
she went from one to two in your
experience can you identify an actor an
actress who's not been able to get a new
studio movie after a breakthrough
performance in a superhero movie
as I sit here now I haven't been asked
to to opine on that but there are lots
of supporting characters in movies that
don't appear in the next movie that but
the but a female star in her
breakthrough movie in a superhero movie
can you identify any actress who's not
gotten another Studio Movie after that
uh
well after
Miss uh heard's breakthrough in 2018 she
did get Aquaman 2.2 was already had the
option for Aquaman all right so she did
miss her did not get any movies after uh
2018 long before the Adam Waldman
statements other than Miss heard can you
identify any actor or actress who's not
gotten another Studio Movie after their
breakthrough in a superhero movie
as I sit here now I haven't been asked
to research that and I and I can't that
would be a normal uh a thing and you're
you're not providing an alternative
number for misheard's damages correct
for the jury
correct I'm not uh providing an
alternative number I think uh you know
she's been more than adequately paid
I've moved to strike after no I've not
been provided another number
that's all I mean if my question was
you're not providing another
number response I think it's In fairness
and with the full answer of the question
your honor it was a it was a yes or no
question he said his answer was no I'm
not going to strike it okay
all right no further questions redirect
um Mr Marks uh in response to some
questions from Mr native half you were
um
discussing some franchise and fantasy uh
movie agreements that you've negotiated
with uh actors could you just describe
some of those for us
I you know I've had such a long career
that I mainly forget what I've done but
I negotiated all the
contracts for uh Pinocchio if you will
that was produced uh you know
um
uh you know is Coming to America the
original is is that a fantasy movie The
Golden Child is at a fantasy movie uh
uh
yeah and and by the way I may have
negotiated contracts uh and ultimately
the film wasn't made uh but as I sit
here now uh those are the only ones that
come to pass if I was looking at my my
resume or going through my files I might
think of others but
there isn't a deal that I haven't made
and I think you also testified in
response to Mr hitoff's natal has
questions that you have negotiated some
deals for Chris Pratt and Paul Rudd do
you recall that testimony yes these are
for a streaming series do you happen to
know if both of those actors have played
Marvel superheroes
I I believe uh they they have but don't
quote me because I you know that's not
my genre okay
um no further questions here all right
thank you Mr Marks you can uh you're
free to stay in the courtroom or or you
can leave okay thank you very much thank
you
all right your next Witness
calls Michael Spindler Michael Spindler
testified previously correct Mr Spindler
all right just a reminder that you're
still under oath okay sir yes all right
thank you
yes sir thank you good morning Mr
Spindler
good morning
uh can you remind the jury who you are
and what you do yes I'm Michael Spindler
I'm a forensic accountant I'm a CPA a
certified fraud examiner amongst some
other certifications
I'm uh with B Riley advisory Services a
national firm that does forensic
accounting bankruptcy and restructuring
work and business evaluations and
appraisals I've got over 40 years of
experience
are you familiar with the testimony
rendered by Miss Arnold in this matter
yes I am
do you understand that Miss Arnold
testified that Ms heard has suffered
economic damages resulting from three
statements made made by Mr Waldman yes I
do
you have an opinion of that claim I do
all right
uh thanks Mr Spindler now you indicated
that you would listen to Ms Arnold and
she testified on behalf of
uh misheard relative to economic damages
have you formed an opinion as to the
testimony and opinion rendered by by Ms
Arnold
yes I have and what's that opinion it is
not adequately supported and it is
unreasonable
there were multiple elements to that
analysis
both damages related to her film career
and to endorsements have you analyzed
both those issues yes I have
what is your opinion of the claims that
have been asserted relative to the film
career and endorsements
okay well
first of all with respect to her damages
calculation there was no calculation per
se
um
she
initially looked at these comparable
actors and seemed to use that as a basis
for numbers
she didn't provide the underlying
calculation she didn't provide
underlying support
and then it appeared as though in her
testimony she backed away a little bit
from that but she still suffers from the
issues of not providing detailed
calculations or support for where those
numbers come from
and she still to some extent appears to
be using some kind of comparable
analysis
all right what is the type of analysis
that you think is appropriate here
well I think and as you heard from the
last witness I think that something that
is anchored in facts taking a look at
historical compensation as a basis for
anticipating future compensation
had you looked at Miss heard's prior
compensation yes I have
I've looked at tax returns that were
provided
for the period of 2013 through 2019.
why do you want to use historical
earnings
but once again you want an analysis is
anchored in fact
I don't believe that Ms Arnold has done
that in her analysis
so here we've got some actual data we've
got some historical compensation and as
the last witness mentioned that often
provides somewhat of a basis for future
anticipated earnings in addition I
believe that Ms Arnold herself said that
she had hoped to be able to look at a
renegotiated salary for Aquaman 2 and
then use that as a basis for future
compensation that being the new kind of
base if you will
were there any years in particular that
you focused on in your analysis
as to Ms Arnold's testimony
uh in terms of the the historical
compensation
well for 2013 through 2019 in total her
compensation was around 10 million
dollars for all those years combined uh
in 2019 the last of those years her
compensation was uh somewhere between
about 2.6 million and 3 million dollars
now that's a good year that's known as a
clean year what do you mean by Clean
year well you know for example 2019 you
had Aquaman was released in December of
2018 and that was a successful film
so in 2019 you've got the benefit of
that kind of success
and you also don't have the any
potential impact from the alleged
defamatory Walden statements that
occurred in April of 2020. so 2019 is
clean of all that
what did you understand
Ms Arnold's methodology to be
her methodology
initially
appeared to be based on these comparable
actors that she had identified
and theoretically
the compensation that they earned
although she doesn't identify what that
compensation is or provide any support
for it or any calculations
what is your opinion of that methodology
from an accounting perspective
uh that methodology was unsound it's
just unsupported there are no numbers
there's no data that she provided and
support for that
what methodology did you understand Ms
Arnold to adopt a trial
okay well it looked like somewhat of a
mix and match approach she used
different approaches I believe for
different elements of the damages
although it's it's still a little bit
unclear to me a little bit vague but uh
there are four basic components that she
was looking at
and we can go through those in any order
you wish all right
with respect to the television series
portion of her analysis
what do you understand that methodology
to be okay
Jackson your honor may we approach it
all right
the earnings from television shows what
was
did you analyze what historical earnings
misheard
had during the period that you were
concerned with relative to television
shows
well yes during 2019 she entered into a
contract in July of 2019 to appear in a
television series
at two hundred thousand dollars per
episode
all right
what about
endorsement deals did you look at what
she had made on endorsement deals during
that period
uh she did have a contract with L'Oreal
uh at one million six hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars
all right
with respect to her movie roles
what were her historical earnings during
that period
well uh certainly for the most recent
years you had the
um
the Warner Brothers deal which was a
four picture deal
the first film was four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
then the first Aquaman was one million
dollars fee base fee then two million
dollars for Aquaman two and uh presuming
that there was an Aquaman 3 that would
have been four million dollars okay
um
why do you look at historical earnings
as part of your analysis
because you want your analysis to be
anchored in facts you wanted to have the
sound methodology and you want to come
up with a reasonable result
so if you take a look at for example
the analysis of Ms Arnold did
it didn't appeal to be but let's let's
just look at the analysis that you're
doing
um
so what you said I think is you wanted
them anchored in facts why
because that provides a sound basis for
coming up with something with reasonable
certainty there's aicpa or American
Institute of certified public accountant
Guidance with respect to reasonable
certainty and those are the basic
elements of it
thank you no further questions all right
cross-examination
hello again Mr Spindler good morning
I'm going to ask you a few questions
that may refer to the statements in
Amber's counterclaim against Mr Depp
when I refer to those statements I'm
going to refer to them as the Depp
Waldman statements do you agree that we
can both be on the same page what I'm
referring to when I say that
uh that's fine you can use your
terminology I'm sorry there's an
injection service hold on can we
approach it okay
so Mr Spindler when I referred to the
depth Waldman statements you understand
me to be referring to the statements in
Miss hard's counterclaim against Mr Depp
correct I'll understand that yes now
you're you're here to provide a rebuttal
opinion to miss Arnold's part of Miss
Arnold's testimony correct
correct you're not providing opinion on
whether misheard suffered defamation by
Mr Depp correct that is true you're not
offering an opinion as to what any of
the underlying facts relating to whether
Mr Depp abused Amber correct
that's correct you're not offering an
opinion as the magnitude of Damages that
you believe misheard may be entitled to
if she proves defamation by Mr Depp
you're just reviewing what Miss Arnold
has said correct that's correct and you
said that you want your analysis to be
accurate in in the facts right
Anchored In fact anchored in facts you'd
agree that what an actor earns in one
period isn't necessarily reflective of
what he or she may earn in future
periods correct
correct and that's because there can be
some variability yes an increase in the
number of roles may lead to Greater
income correct I'm sorry could you
repeat that I was speaking it in here
one of the reasons that what yearn in
one period may not be reflected of or
reflective of what an actress May or in
future periods is because an increase in
the number of roles may lead to Greater
income correct
the number of roles or the particular
project itself yes sure getting better
roles may lead to Greater income correct
correct and the same is true for an
endorsement as an actress's profile
grows the amount of money that she may
be able to earn from endorsements grows
as well correct
it can so it depends what misheard
earned from say 2013 to 2019 that you
testify to isn't necessarily reflective
of what she might earn over the next
five years correct
not necessarily it is a good indicator
though and you'd agree that from 2013 to
2019 in terms of earnings and star power
that misheard's career trajectory was on
the upswing correct there was a a slight
increase during that period of time in
her earnings from 2013 through 2019. and
you'd agree that that was as a result of
getting more lucrative roles right yes
now you're not a causation expert right
you're just a damages expert that's
correct so you're not testifying as to
whether the Depp Waldman statements
caused her to lose any roles correct
that's correct and you're not offering
any opinion as to whether the depth
Waldman statements kept her from being
considered for roles that she otherwise
would have been considered considered
for correct
that's correct I'm not testifying on
causation issues and you can't speak to
what opportunities may never have
materialized for Amber as a result of
the dep Waldman statements correct
yeah I've not done those calculations
and you don't have an opinion about
whether or not misheard could have
renegotiated a contract for Aquaman 2
correct that was not part of my work and
you don't have an opinion on the impact
that additional exposure or press
coverage or magazine covers or
interviews would have had on Miss herd's
career correct
correct I'm just looking at Ms Arnold's
calculations you 've never served as an
expert witness before to calculate
damages based on Lost roles by an
actress resulting from defamation
against that person correct
I've been involved in defamation cases
but I've not done the calculations as an
expert witness who testified thereto
and there's never been an instance in
which you have served as an expert
witness
in a case to calculate damages based on
alleged defamation against an actress
correct
correct and you're not offering any
expert opinion on what impact the
alleged defamation by Mr death has had
on Miss heard's career correct
I'm sorry one more time you're not
offering any expert opinion on what
impact the Depp Waldman statements by Mr
Depp has had on Miss heard's career
correct
other than taking a look at Ms Arnold's
calculations and you're not offering any
expert opinion about what impact if any
social media coverage of this case or
misheard may have had on misheard's
Career correct you're correct that's
other experts can we approach two other
questions thank you all right
for you okay all right thank you Miss
Finley you have a seat in the courtroom
or you're free to go thank you
all right your next Witness
plaintiff calls Doug Banya your honor
okay he spelled last name for me
b-a-n-i-a thank you
foreign
so just a reminder that you're still
under oath okay sir thank you
foreign
good afternoon
yourself to the jury please uh yes hi
Doug Bania
um I am from nevium intellectual
property Consultants based in San Diego
I value intellectual property I provide
litigation support uh in infringement
and defamation cases as I'm doing today
and I use internet and social media
analytics and both of those services
since you last testified in this case
the jury has heard testimony from Ronald
Schnell and Catherine Arnold are you
familiar with their testimony yes were
you asked to analyze their testimony and
provide opinions in response yes I was
have you formed opinions in response to
the testimony of Mr Schnell and Ms
Arnold I have generally what are those
opinions
generally
um you know Mr Schnell provided no
evidence of a correlation between the
Waldman statements and the hashtags and
the spikes of those hashtags on Twitter
a second based on my internet and social
media analytics uh investigation I've
concluded that the alleged comparable
actors that Miss Arnold came up with are
not comparable with misheard and then
thirdly Mr Schnell
and Miss Arnold both failed to provide
any evidence of a causation as it
relates to the Waldman statements
causing any economic harm to misheard
all right let's um let's dig into those
opinions a little bit
um you're familiar with the testimony of
Mr Schnell that there are more than 2.7
million alleged negative tweets related
to misheard between January 2018 and
June 2021 yes and what's your
understanding of how Mr snow identified
those particular 2.7 million tweets yeah
so essentially Mr Schnell
um chose
hashtags that he felt were negative
towards Miss heard those hashtags that
range from of justice for Johnny Depp
um Amber Heard is an abuser Amber turd
and the hash uh tag we just don't like
you Amber so then he used those hashtags
and he searched through using the
Twitter API searched through various
tweets and then came up with any uh
tweets that were using those hashtags
did you conduct an analysis of those
tweets
yes I was given that exact uh the data
that Mr Schnell used on a hard drive so
yes I I dug into that data as well and
what was the purpose of your analysis so
what I'm trying to do and what's that
issue of the case today at this point is
you know were these tweets did they
contain the Waldman statements that's
what we're where we're at right now are
the Waldman statements so I wanted to
analyze those tweets to determine uh
which ones and if any contain the Walton
statements and what's your understanding
of what the Wildman statements are
so my understanding is they're the three
there's three Walden statements that
were published uh in the Daily Mail the
Daily Mail is a a UK tabloid and
um
Mr
um Arnold
um
was quoted in the in three of those
articles
um and those dates were on April 8th
2020 uh April 27 2020 and on June 24th
2020 and my understanding that those
quotes
those quotes I I I'm sorry I think I
said the wrong name but those quotes are
the only remaining in this case
analyze the timing of the tweets that we
were talking about as compared to the
timing of the Wildman statements and
that's exactly what I did so I wanted to
look at the Waldman statements look at
the dates that they happened and then
analyze those as a compared to the
Twitter data that I had
have you prepared a demonstrative that
reflects that aspect of your analysis
yes
um your honor may I approach yes
did you
show Council
foreign
will just be marked for identification
as demonstrations
and can be published to the jury
can you explain to the jury what this
demonstrative shows yes
um so this shows
um the total hashtags and tweets that Mr
Schnell was analyzing this is the
summary data that there are tweets that
are running from January 2018 to June of
2021 and again these are related to the
four four hashtags that I discussed
um whenever I get an assignment such as
this when I'm dealing with a defamatory
statement that's allegedly gone viral
online uh where there's economic damages
involved and there's a lot of data
involved I like to take the data and I
like to do a 30 000 foot view of the
data to see what I'm looking at to see
if there's anything interesting odd
different about the data and and the
first thing that I noticed is 35
of the tweets were prior to the Waldman
statements so again remember my
assignment is to determine if the Walden
statements are part of the the tweets
that Mr Schnell analyzed so obviously if
these tweets were prior to the Waldman
statements in no way could they have
anything to do with the Waldman
statement so that was the first issue
that I noticed then I noticed uh what I
like to call kind of the alleged to
family Tory time frame and as I
discussed that's when the um
Walden statements were published that's
the date down here you know the first
one was in the beginning of April and
and the last one which is the third one
was at the end of June but what I found
interesting is only two percent of all
of the tweets happened during this
Walden statement period so really these
are just observations and for me there
were red flags that I made note of and
then I just continued with my analysis
um what other work could be performed in
connection with forming your opinions
about the purportedly negative tweets
yeah so now I realize that 35 are
relevant and two percent can only happen
during this this important period I just
continued to dig into the 2.79 million
um uh tweets that Mr Schnell provided
and Tom can we take that one down
and Mr Banya have you prepared another
demonstrative that depicts that analysis
that you were just describing yes
foreign
I'll give you time to look at it sir
all right plaintiffs if you turn my
microphone sorry no objection has a
demonstrative okay all right play news
exhibit 1294 will be marked to
identification as a demonstrative and
will be published to the jury
thank you your honor
Mr Banya can you explain what this
demonstrative shows
yes this is showing
um the various spikes
um
as it relates to the hashtags that Mr
Chanel testified about this is actually
an exhibit or a demonstrative that he
used in his testimony what this is
showing are the largest largest spikes
related to the hashtag Justice for
Johnny Depp I don't know if you remember
his testimony or any of his
demonstratives the other three hashtags
did Spike at the same time but a very
small Spike so what I'm showing you here
are the six top spikes in Mr schnell's
analysis
and what's important here again is the
very first Spike and the largest Spike
again uh happened before the Waldman
statements so what I'm trying to figure
out is what tweets were related to the
Waldman statements so this number one
Spike which is the biggest like was
prior to the Waltman statements so it's
irrelevant to the case
and then the second thing I noticed that
was interesting here is here are the
dates in Gray right here this is the
time in which the Walden statements
happened and you're going to notice as
we discussed before only two percent of
the tweets happen during that time but I
found it very interesting for such a
viral event that has potentially caused
such economic harm
there's no spikes in this area and
actually you're going to see that Mr
Waltman you know
his uh statement came out here in in the
first April 2020 article then the second
one came out here and then the third one
came out in June there's actually a
downward use of the spike a downward use
of the hashtags so I'm not seeing any
correlation as it relates to the Waldman
statements and and any spikes here as it
relates to the hashtags Mr Chanel chose
did you analyze each of the spikes that
are depicted here
yeah so what I did is
um I looked at the six different spikes
and you're going to notice that each
Spike represents a month so the second
Spike you know is July of 2020 and so on
to the sixth fight going to April 2021
and what I did is I don't know if you
remember my last testimony when I went
into Google search and I'm able to go
into Google search I went in and I typed
in Amber Heard and then after you hit
search you can use the tool and you can
go back in time and I chose each six of
these dates to go back in time to see
what what was the media talking about
back then you know what what was the the
general public being fed as it relates
to Amber Heard back during those spikes
and what I found is none of them well I
actually analyzed the top three search
results because they represent 50 to 70
percent of what people click on and now
I realized that none of had anything to
do with the Walden statements
are you aware of Mr schnell's testimony
that the tweets using the four hashtags
he looked at were mathematically
correlated
yes what does that mean
so what Mr Chanel is saying which is
irrelevant to this case is the four
hashtags that he randomly chose they
tend to go up and down together and
that's why he had these spikes here so
the correlation there is how those four
hashtags work or dance together going up
and down but
first of all the hashtags have nothing
to do with the Waldman statements and
the fact that there's a correlation with
with the hashtags is irrelevant to this
case because we're dealing with a Walden
statements which none of that
correlation analysis he did had to do
with
how do you know that the correlation
doesn't have anything to do with the
Wildman statements
um can I clear this at all
no oh yeah
um well first of all I know because that
that would happen right here you know if
if if when Mr Walden one of his quotes
was published you would see a big spike
right here and then you would see maybe
a little noise down here and then the
third time you might see a big second
time a big spike and the third time a
big spike that's not here so that's
telling me there's no correlation
between the Walden statements and in
this hashtag use and then I've actually
provided evidence that there's no
correlation because I analyze each of
these spikes and none of them had to do
with the Waldman statements is
mathematical correlation the same as
causation
no
why not
I mean correlation is simply a
relationship between the two or more
variables or two or more things in this
case uh
the the correlation question is
did when when when the Waldman
statements were published at the same
time did you see a correlation with
spikes in these hashtags and again
you can we clear this
you see none of that right here it's
actually a downward Trend there's no
spikes there's no correlation so you
know again Mr Schnell proved provided no
evidence of any correlation
what correlation opinion did he die
during his testimony
well he provided the correlation that
the four hashtags you know Spike
together but again this a the hashtags
have nothing to do with the Walden
statements and the fact that they're
correlating or moving together is
irrelevant to the case because the case
is about the Waltman statements so what
is causation then
so causation is where one thing causes a
change in the other so as it relates to
this case
did the Waldman statements cause
misheard to have economic harm in other
words did the Waldman statements cause
misheard not to make as much money in
her career and again Mr Schnell provided
no evidence of this Miss Arnold provided
no evidence of this
and as a matter of fact during
Miss Arnold's testimony yesterday she
didn't even know what causation was you
know she was asked do you know the
difference between causation and
correlation and she said that she's not
a semantics expert or we're not talking
about the words you know when it comes
to damages you have to prove causation
prior to calculating damages you know so
there is no causation that's proven here
therefore it damages uh analysis is not
appropriate
did you hear Mr Schnell testify that he
agreed with your opinion in this case
yes and what's your understanding of the
opinion that he agreed with
well he agreed that he failed to link
the spikes in the hashtags on Twitter to
the Waldman statements did he try to do
that he well he tried to do that but
well again his analysis was looking at
the word Waldman and looking at the word
Wald minion and then trying to say that
25
of the tweets included those two terms
but first of all Waldman isn't the issue
here it's the Waldman statements and
Wald minion I don't even know what that
is but it's not relevant to this case
we can I think take that one down please
Tom
Mr Banya what other work have you done
in connection with forming your opinions
about Mr schnell's testimony
again the assignment was to determine if
the Waldman statements were part of the
the Tweet so I continued to dig in uh
you know to the data uh I believe the
next step is now that I've excluded you
know the 35 percent that was before the
Waldman statements because they were
irrelevant I wanted to really analyze
from the April 2024 word to see if any
of those tweets uh you know were
contained the Walton statements
did you prepare a demonstrative that
reflects that analysis that you did yes
I did your anime approach again all
right yes ma'am
any objections sir no objection has a
democracy all right we'll market for
identification as plaintiff's 1295 as to
Manchester maybe published in the church
so Mr Banya did you consider um the
content of the statements made by
Waldman as part of the work that you did
yes
yes so here I reviewed the Waldman
statements again and what I wanted to do
is I wanted to determine what if any
tweets included the Walden statements so
what I went I went back to the Walden
statements and I I came up with you know
key terms and key themes for those
Waltman statements which are listed here
uh you know the Waldman statements were
about abuse hoax sexual violence hoax
and fake sexual violence so what I did
is I we're now dealing with a 1.2
million tweets because you know we're
starting in April 2020 because that's
when the Waldman State statements uh
started and what I did is I searched the
1.2 million
um tweets you know for these three
phrases and I determined that there were
751 tweets that included those key terms
uh which is 0.06 percent of the 1.2
million
and then as I was sifting and sorting
and analyzing this data I realized that
a lot of these tweets had the exact same
language you know it was interesting to
see it was exact exact same tweet
because I'm analyzing the language to
see if it matches one of these three I
realize that a lot of these tweets were
Retreat retweets likes or shares so
therefore I eliminated uh any of those
and I came down uh with 95 unique tweets
and then what I did from there is I
analyzed those to determine if any of
these terms were in there and I
identified five tweets that were related
to the Waldman statements
do any of the hashtags Mr Schnell
analyzed include the words from the
Wellman statements
no no they don't and you know because
I'm rebutting
um Miss Arnold you know her testimony
yesterday she was saying that the Walden
statements caused these hashtags then
throughout her testimony she walked that
back and admitted no none of these
tweets have anything to do with the
Waldman statements they don't include
the Waldman statements you know these
hashtags are only hashtags that Schnell
in his opinion felt that they were
negative towards misheard
based on your expertise what are your
overall opinions about Mr schnell's
testimony and the Twitter hashtag data
you know Mr Schnell provided no evidence
that
any of the tweets were related to the
Waldman statements
um Mr Schnell there's no correlation
there he also provided no evidence that
there's any causation that you know the
Waldman statements caused any economic
harm towards misheard
your honor I'm about to switch to a
different topic I don't know if you want
to break now or push all right it's
going to be a a little while I assume a
little bit more yeah okay yeah let's go
ahead and break for lunch ladies and
gentlemen okay do not discuss the case
and do not do any outside research okay
foreign
all right
thank you sir
all right are we ready for the jury oh
okay sure
all right
foreign
foreign
your next question
Mr Vanya before lunch we were talking
about your opinions in response to the
testimony of Mr Schnell did you also
analyze the testimony of Ms Arnold in
this case yes I did and are you aware of
her opinion that Ms heard's career would
have followed the same trajectory as
that of Jason Momoa Gal Gadot Zendaya
Ana de armas and Chris Pine if not for
the Walden statements yes
what's your understanding of Ms Arnold's
basis for her opinion that Miss heard's
career should have been similar to that
of those identified actors
um Miss Arnold stated that
when producers or her Industries looking
to hire talent and actors that it's
important to best understand the The
public's perception
of the actors that they're considering
and that it's important to you're
looking to social media to see what what
is happening with the actors they're
considering for either a movie or even a
an endorsement opportunity with
companies
um
so that that was her approach
and is that that she followed in
providing her analysis of those
purportedly comparable actors
no although she stated that she went in
and uh brought in these comparable
alleged comparable actors and without
really the reasoning behind that
did you conduct
on your expertise in social media and
internet analytics have misheard
compared to the actors to whom Ms Arnold
compares her I did and what did you find
well since Miss Arnold stated that the
proper approach is looking at the public
perspective looking into social media
and she did not do that I felt that was
the best approach to do this based on
her her words so yes I did go into
um you know best understanding the
public perspective of um misheard and
the alleged comparable actors using Q
scores then I also went and did some
analysis on online and on social media
as well can you briefly remind the jury
what Q scores are yeah again Q score is
a measure how well a celebrity it could
be a cartoon character could be a sports
person how well they're known how well
they're liked and how much they're
disliked and it's it's in Industry
standard tool that's used uh it's not
just focused on the movies that they're
in but it's focused on them as actors
but also what's happening in their
personal lives uh come to play as well
so that's how Q scores are typically
used did you prepare a demonstrative
that reflects the Q score analysis you
completed yes I do your honor may
approach again all right thank you
thank you no objection to the democracy
all right we'll identify plano's 1296
for identification and public to the
jury
Mr Vanya what what point in time do
these Q scores represent that are
reflected on your demonstrative
so this these are the winter
2019 Q scores
that are reflected here and what was
important for me is I I wanted to find Q
scores
that represented misheard after Aquaman
and you know remember Aquaman is
December of 2018. these Q scores were
gathered January and February of 19 but
before the Waldman statements
and what did you find based on the Q
scores that you looked at
so as you see here on the left are
positive Q scores and you know the
higher than number the better as you can
see uh you know Miss Godot has the
highest Q score out of the of the group
of actors here uh at a 28 but you're
going to notice Miss heard has the
lowest positive Q score she has a nine
so I find that very interesting that if
she doesn't appear to fit in as a
comparable with these alleged comparable
actors I think what's also interesting
is the average Q score for All actors
being scored at that time which include
all the alleged comparable actors here
score at an average of 17 and you can
see again she is nine well below that
and then on the right side you're going
to see the negative Q scores so this is
how much people dislike you
um you know so the lower the score is
better you can see Mr memo is over here
with the lowest at an eight but you can
see Miss heard is over here at a 28
which is was quite a difference uh you
know a 20-point difference from Mr Mamoa
and also a 10 point difference uh you
know from the average of all actors so
she is very much little uh her positive
score is very low and her negative score
is is very high which tells me that she
does not fit in as comparable as it
relates to these alleged comparable
actors
um what opinions did you form based on
that Q score analysis
uh my opinions as it relates to these
key scores is
um you know Miss Arnold used these
actors as allegedly comparable actors
um
but really listening to her testimony
yesterday it appears that she's
abandoned this approach I don't think
she's using these comparable actors of
these alleged comparable actors anymore
she's more reliant on her experience and
I agree with that
did Ms Arnold offer a criticism of your
use of the Q scores here
you did yes and what's your
understanding what that criticism is
well what I believe she was saying is
that I should have ran Q scores for
these allegedly comparable actors after
each of their Breakout
films which
um I disagree first of all Q scores
doesn't work like that Q scores are
available twice a year so it's not that
I could pick a month or a different
month for each of of the Q score actors
um so I feel that you know what was
important for me and this doesn't always
happen when when I'm using Q scores you
can get this perfect moment in time as
Miss Earth said I'm sorry but as Miss
Arnold said that you know Aquaman was
Miss heard's breakout moment you know so
these scores reflect that the breakout
moment and and they're terrible cue
scores
would your analysis change if you had
used Ms Arnold's logic with respect to
the the timing of the Q score
I mean if you really think about what uh
Miss Arnold was saying is she's saying
that she thinks Q scores are the highest
for each actor right after their
breakout moment so I would think of
anything uh these Q scores could have
been a bit lower uh because it's not
right after their breakout moment but
what again what's important for me is
the fact that these scores reflect you
know who Amber Heard was at the time
before the Walden statements but after
the Aquaman release
um we can take that one down Tom thank
you
what other work have you done um in
connection with forming your opinions in
this case
um again taking the advice from Miss
Arnold it's important she says the
industry looks into social media what
their followings are like uh you know
with the numbers as it relates to their
followers
um you know again what is the public
perception of them so I I analyzed uh
their social media accounts but prior to
the the Waldman statement so and how did
you do that yeah so what I did I don't
know if you're all familiar with the
archive.org they have a tool called the
Wayback machine what archive.org does is
it it archives the internet so you can
go back in time to see what websites and
web pages used to look like
in the past not all the time can you
actually get celebrities social media
accounts to have been archived but we
were fortunate that each of the alleged
comparable actors social media accounts
were in archive.org work so I was able
to go back in time prior to the Waldman
statements to see what what the
following activity was for each of the
alleged comparable actors
Mr Banya did you prepare a demonstrative
that reflects your social media analysis
yes
ma'am
no objection to the demonstration all
right we'll market for identification
purposes plaintiffs 1297 and published
Mr value could you tell the jury what
you found when you looked at the social
media
yeah so what I found again this is prior
to the Walden statements you know first
thing you're going to notice here is not
all actors use social media you're going
to see Mr Pine uh doesn't have Facebook
Twitter or Instagram and memo and
armists don't use Facebook or Twitter
but what's important to look at is
um you have misheard prior to the Walden
statements with 3.8
um Instagram followers and 142
500 Twitter followers and then you you
move down to Gal Gadot with 37 million
Instagram followers compared to her 3.8
million uh and you know 2 million 2.3
million uh Twitter followers compared to
miss heard's 142 000 and you can then
even go down to Zendaya with 65 point
million point nine and 17.2 million uh
Twitter followers what this is telling
me is really you know more people are
interested in miscado and Zendaya and
even uh Mr Momoa then misheard on social
media it just tells me a lot people are
interested in these actors as opposed to
misheard more of a following Hue scores
of well-liked less disliked so it kind
of fits into the analysis of determining
whether or not these alleged comparable
actors are actually comparable
your expertise what are your overall
opinions about Ms Arnold's analysis of
the so-called comparable actors yes
again you know it appears that she's
abandoned this approach but and I agree
with that I I feel that you know through
the Q score analysis and the uh social
media analysis that they're just not
comparable
Mr Banya based on and all the analysis
you did in this case what are your
overall opinions yes my overall opinions
are that Mr Schnell failed to prove any
causal connection with the Waldman
statements and the uh search or the
hashtag activity those spikes as it
relates to Twitter there's no causal
connection there
my second opinion is you know based on
my social media and Q score analysis uh
Miss Arnold's comparable alleged
comparable actors are not comparable and
then third Miss Arnold and Mr Schnell
both failed to prove any causation as it
relates to the Waldman statements
causing economic harm to misheard so you
know as a damages expert which Miss
Arnold is you need to take into
consideration causation before you can
calculate damages you look at damages
and you look at this allegedly damaging
event and not only do you have to prove
that a hundred percent of the damage is
because of these Waldman statements she
didn't even consider uh coven it
happened at the same time you know a lot
of actors probably made a lot less money
because of covet maybe films didn't get
made and you know when you do do an
analysis of Damages improve causation
but you also have to look at everything
else that might have caused this alleged
economic harm and she didn't look into
any of that she didn't even know what
causation was so I don't think the
damages is it the appropriate approach
in this case
no further questions your honor all
right cross-examination
Mr good afternoon Mr Banyan hi yeah
you're not a damages expert correct
I am a damages expert but not providing
any quantitative damages opinions in
this case in this case okay
and is it your testimony that only if a
person repeats the Waldman depth
statements could they be related to the
defamation
say that one more time are you saying
that a person literally has to repeat
the Waldman debt
statements in a in a tweet for them to
be related to the defamation
uh no if you looked at my analysis I did
pick the three themes as it relates to
the tweets and I either analyze those
themes and I came up with five examples
of when those themes were used and you
ran searches for quote abuse hoax sexual
violence hoax and fake sexual violence
and you ran all those in quotes correct
I did so only if a person used
a tweet with those words in that order
and with that spacing would they hit on
your searches correct objection compound
overall
yes so I used them in quotes because you
know the hoax could be used in many
other contexts so I wanted to make sure
I was fitting my search with the theme
of the Walden States so if someone
tweeted misheard faked sexual violence
that wouldn't appear in your that
wouldn't appear in your searches correct
faked with an ed
it would not okay
and any and if they use two spaces
between abuse and hoax
that wouldn't fit in your search that's
correct okay
did you
and it tweets 200 a tweet can only be
280 characters correct that's correct
all right so certain of the Walden Depp
statements
a person could not tweet the whole thing
in one tweet correct the whole statement
in one tweet
the Walden statement correct
um no you could not tweet that into
those entire quotes did you make any
determination if there was an online
bullying campaign against Mr Depp after
Miss Herz op-ed
I didn't look into any uh online
bullying campaign for misheard from this
Mr dad did you determine if there were
tweets harassing Mr depth that quoted
from Miss Herz op-ed
no my assignment was to determine if the
Waldman statements were part of the the
tweets that Mr Chanel provided I was I
was rebodying him and in your analysis
of when you when you testified before
you never look to see if the op-ed was
quoted anywhere correct
objection your honor may we approach
all right questions withdrawn next
question
um now
you have no objection to miss Arnold's
use of comparables correct
just use the comparables in general
I listened to her testimony in my
understanding that she abandoned that uh
that approach but as it relates to my
testimony today uh my opinion was
related to those specific alleged
comparable actors that they were not
comparable you're not offering opinion
as to who the appropriate comparables
should be to miss her correct correct
okay
and
um
you you testified just before about the
cue scores of misheard
and the comp and the comparables that
was
uh plaintiff's exhibit 1296 correct
I don't know what uh 1296 means okay the
the demonstrative in front of you mine
yes that's correct
um
and you said that those were all for the
winter of 2019. I said Miss herds were
from the winter of 2019. because isn't
it true that none of the rest of these
people were from the winter of 2019
correct that's correct okay
in fact uh Mr momoa's was from the
summer
of 2020 of 2020. that's correct not all
elective comparable actors had Q scores
for that date what was important for me
to get Miss heard's Q scores right after
Aquaman but before the Waldman
statements if you weren't comparing
Apples to Apples correct
I wouldn't say that I'm saying that
that's not the exact same years well so
in the winter of 2019 that Q score comes
out that the field date the field work
dates for that is from January 22nd 2019
to February 7th 2019 correct that is
correct so that would be
started so the field work would be
starting almost a
immediately after Aquaman just came out
correct yeah and her the Star is Born
moment yes you'd agree that for the
winter of 2020 where you took Jason
momoa's Q score would have more time to
account for the rise and popularity of
the film Aquaman correct
well actually if I use Miss Arnold's
suggestion the these celebrities tend to
have you know the the celebrity moment
right after they have their breakout
film so I disagree with that I think
maybe his Q scores could be lower as it
relates to when I use them
you'd agree that for the winter of 2020
Mr momoa's Q score would have more time
to account for the rise and popularity
of the film Aquaman
I don't know if it accounts for the rise
of popularity again using Miss Arnold's
uh words usually a q score will be the
highest after right after the film like
I did measure misheard
all right do you show
thank you
if you if you look on page 177
of your deposition transcript you see
that I don't see a page is that but you
handed me
you don't see page 177 um four pages
four pages per oh yes thank you
and I asked you
at lines six through ten
you'd agree that for the winter of 2020
Jason Momo was Q score would have more
time to account for the rise of
popularity in the film Aquaman and you
answered yes
at that time as I am a rebuttal expert
to Ms Arnold based on her testimony I've
learned something new from her
you did and you didn't look at Miss
hurt's Q score for summer of 2020
correct she doesn't have any and Miss de
armas had a lower lower familiarity
score than miss her correct
um if I don't have that in front of me
but if you're saying that yes okay and
Miss Thomas's career trajectory has gone
up since the summer of 2020 correct
I I don't know I didn't analyze her
career trajectory okay
um
could we could you put up planets a
trial exhibit 1297 that was the
demonstrative
Mr armis has
less Instagram followers than Miss Eric
correct correct
and by Miss heard has more than double
the Instagram followers of Mr arms
correct yes okay
and isn't it true that you get more
social media followers the longer you're
on social media
not necessarily it doesn't work that way
it depends on many other factors and so
Mr armis had a lower familiarity score
and less Instagram followers yet your
testimony is that she would not be a
proper comparable to miss her
that's correct
and you're not offering a different set
of people who should be comparables
correct that's correct okay thank you
now
you understand that Mr Waldman has been
banned from Twitter for life for
harassing and for her correct
I I don't know that but if that's the
case
and you understand that Mr Waltman
appealed the decision to Twitter and
they have confirmed his ban for Life
objection your honor may we approach on
this one okay sure
foreign
you agree that in looking at Mr
schnell's Data 65 percent of the uses of
negative hashtags relating to misheard
occurred
between April 1st 2020 and June 15 2021
correct okay
and you would agree that five of the six
highest spikes of the negative hashtags
were after the Deb Waltman statements
correct
correct okay
and
where you talked about the February
2020 Spike
and the 65 by the way even includes the
February 2020 Spike of tweets correct
that's correct well there was no spike
in Feb 2020 during the Waldman
statements well
the spike in February 2020 was before
the Waldman statements right
I would have you can we pull up the
chart again if you want to talk about
the spikes sure can you put up 1294
number one
number one yeah that Spike happened
before the Waldman Stadium okay and
there was hardly any activity
in negative hashtags until February 2020
correct
that's correct
and you understand that the spike in
February 2020 was related to the partial
tape that Mr Waldman and Mr Depp leaked
to the Daily Mail Right
I'm aware that the Articles were related
to heard admitting to hitting death and
you understand that Mr Waldman testified
that Mr death and Mr Waldman met with
the Daily Mail in person to provide the
partial tapes of the Daily Mail
objection your honor
hey she's talking about he talked about
what the number one related to what's
the objection sorry lack of foundation
and I'm asking I'm asking if you don't
if he knows or he doesn't all right uh
we'll rule
so what's important to me is the fact
that this spike is prior to Thursday do
you know if this if you know if Mr
Waldman testified that Mr Depp and he
met with the Daily Mail in person to
provide the partial tape no in February
of 2020. you don't know one word that's
the relevance in my opinion okay and the
spike in July of 2020 came right after
the last defamatory statement by Mr Depp
and Mr Walden correct
of the July Spike which is number two uh
is not related to the Walden statements
and it uh there are articles related to
abuse between herd and Depp and feces
found in depths fed and that's based on
Google searches you did that's correct
okay in the July but the July spike in
time
came in after the June 27 2020 a
defamatory statement by Mr death and Mr
Wallman correct
that's correct okay and as and five of
the six spikes came after the defamatory
statements correct after the Waldman
statements yes okay now you testified
before that you eliminated shares and
likes of the debt waldman's statements
from your analysis right
repeat that please did you say that you
eliminated shares and likes
of tweets that included the debt Wellman
statements
that's correct when I was doing my
analysis I noticed the exact same text
was a part of many of these tweets don't
don't share them likes disseminate the
negative information
that's quite possible okay
and you agree right that use of the term
Waldman or Wald minion occurred over 25
percent of the time in the negative
tweets
toward misheard from April 2020 through
January 2021 correct although it's
irrelevant to this case it has nothing
to do with the Waldman statements that's
what Mr Schnell says you don't disagree
with it you don't disagree with the
search results correct
although has nothing to do with this
case or the Waldman statements I do not
disagree so if people are tweeting about
Adam Waldman
and or while the minion at the same time
as tweeting negative hashtags
hashtags about Amber Heard that has it's
your testimony that they have nothing to
do with this case
the hashtags have nothing to do with
this case
that's that's what you're saying okay
yeah okay and even if they include the
negative Hashtags with Walt Mr Waldman
's name and wall minion you're saying
they have nothing to do with the
defamatory statements all four hashtags
that smell used had nothing to do with
the Waldman statements Waldman himself
has nothing to do with the Waldman
statements we're talking about the
Walden statements here Walt minion
I don't even know what that is but again
it has nothing to do with this case and
it's not related to the the Walden
statements that's what's important and
the reason you're saying they're not
related to the Waldman statements is
because someone didn't literally copy
what Adam Waldman said in the Daily Mail
and tweet it out well I looked at enough
tweets that included the name Waltman
that have nothing to do with anything
negative or the Waldman statement no
they must have been had to have the
negative hashtags toward misheard
because the only way that those would
have been in the data you looked at
would have had the negative hashtags
towards misheard he wasn't look you it
was looking at that Universe correct
well first of all I don't agree that the
justice for Johnny Depp is a negative
hashtag towards Amber Heard so listen
the assignment was to determine if the
tweets that Mr Schnell presented were
related or included the Waltman
statements in your review of the tweets
related to miss her you cannot point to
any that were positive toward Ms hurt
correct again I was not looking for that
and you didn't not review the hashtag
Johnny Justice for Johnny Depp during
the time frame from April 1st 2020 to
January 1st 2020 to see if there were
any that were not negative toward miss
her
I did not look into anything as it
relates to anything other than what
relates to the Waltman statements that's
what's that issue here today as we sit
in court
and you didn't form any statistical
analysis to rule out the Waldman
statement's impact on the hashtags
correct correct you did not analyze
whether media and press coverage other
than the Waldman statements affected
Miss hurt's career correct correct okay
looking at
um
the exhibit that's in front of you where
you have the numbers here
those you said are related to Google
Google searches
the the one through six correct yes okay
and can we put out
um
plaintiffs 888
and we get to start at one do you
understand that your
okay
oh thanks
and
888 it's page 76 these are the documents
you relied upon for your opinion today
yes and are these the search the where
it has the different letters these are
the searches
uh that you ran for the various time
frames and the articles that came up for
numbers one through six correct
no I mean obviously document 1A is the
herd supplemental expert witness
disclosure these are these are documents
that I used throughout the time I've
been working on this project so these
aren't related to those one through six
numbers
okay these are documents you relied upon
for your opinion today
these are documents that I relied upon
when I presented my my designation
for your opinion today that you're
offering today
yeah these are the documents that yes
I've relied on throughout this entire
this case okay and actually Michelle
could you turn in this designation to
um
let's see
uh
hold on one second
go can you just scroll down
yeah I keep scrolling
keep going
okay stop
this was the chart you provided with
your designation for your opinions in
this case correct
yes okay and
it's it's similar to the chart that we
had before we had before with the one
through six correct that's correct and
where it has the various boxes
it's talking about documents 6E through
6h for instance related to death wanting
to have herd replaced on Aquaman
yes
and you you prepared this chart correct
yeah this was part of my designation I'd
like to have this page um as a
demonstrative
hey rather I do have an objection if I
might be heard all right
foreign
foreign
other than
so as I understand it your
the way you determined that the tweets
were not related to the Waldman
statements was that you looked at time
and then you ran certain Google searches
correct
correct and then the top three hits came
up
correct and you were and then you look
through the article to see if the
Waldman statements were there
so as it relates to any trending event
any defamation that's happened online
any allegations of of economic loss
because something went viral going to
Google looking at the spikes in time and
going back in time to see what was
happening on those top three sites will
give you an indication of the best
results that were being served at that
time so something viral that's happening
would appear most likely in those top
three results and just so the records
clear if we could go back to page 76 of
this document
number six a
through
6n going to the next page those are the
those are the headlines of the searches
that you found correct okay
and you don't disagree that the that
negative tweets toward misheard have
continued throughout your throughout the
analysis of the tweets correct
I'm not looking at whether there are
negative tweets or those hashtags are
negative I'm determining if those tweets
are related to the Walden statements
okay and you you haven't there's not you
have no so you have no opinion whether
the tweets were positive or negative
towards miserved that's what that's what
you're saying yes I'm just analyzing
whether or not they're related to the
Walden statements okay thank you nothing
bud
I have no further questions of this
witness your honor thank you Mr Vanya
yes
thank you
ladies and gentlemen we're going to take
a brief recess for you at this point
um
sorry do not discuss the case and don't
do any outside research sorry we'll just
take a short break
foreign
just so that we're on the same page you
can have a seat
keep standing the whole time all right
just so we're on the same page with Mr
Knight's testimony actually could Mr
Knight go back out
please
all right all right so we're on the same
page with Mr Knight's testimony
um there was a rule on Witnesses however
Mr Knight's a rebuttal witness
um
the purpose of excluding Witnesses uh
from the courtroom
usually it's a courtroom is to deprive a
later witness of the opportunity to
shape testimony to correspond with that
of an earlier Witness
um the issue we have here obviously if
it was a direct witness in the direct
testimony you had time to do Rule and
Witnesses let them know about the rule
on Witnesses with the rebuttal witness
it's a little different because
um they didn't know they were going to
be a witness you didn't know they were
going to be a witness I understand that
part the problem is the courtroom in
this particular case
appears to be the world so what we have
to do here is I'm going to do a voidir
and I'll allow both sides to ask
questions as well of Mr Knight to see
what he has seen of the case and I'm
just going to use the factors that the
case law in Virginia uses which the
factors to consider because the court
does have broad discretion to permit or
prohibit a witness to testify in this
particular circumstance so the factors
I'm going to consider is if the
impropriety was intentional which we'll
find out the Prejudice attached to it
also if the excluded witness learned
about substance substantive aspects of
the case from an earlier testifying
witness and rather that knowledge had
any effect on his or her testimony so
those are the three factors I'm going to
look at in weighing this decision so
keep that in mind when you do your Void
deer and it's my understanding that the
evidence that Mr Knight will testify
only relates to Hicksville is that
correct okay all right now we can have
Mr Knight
all right sir Mr Knight if you could
come forward
to be sworn
sure if you could just have a seat
please
sir what's what we're doing is I'm just
going to ask you a few questions outside
the presence of the jury then the
attorneys are going to ask you a few
questions okay then I'm going to have
you step back outside after that okay no
problem all right what's your full name
sir
Morgan Higby night okay
okay sir um before I can let you testify
I just want to ask you a few questions
um have you seen any of the trial that's
been going on for the past six weeks
um approximately five weeks ago
a friend of mine texted me that
Hicksville was mentioned and I watched a
little clip like it was mentioned which
clip did you watch
um I believe it was uh
somebody testifying about I think it was
the security guard testifying maybe
about Hicksville or
um
I forget exactly who was testifying
but it was something where Hicksville
was mentioned and uh it was uh about
something about a wrist or something
like that all right and what did you do
after that at some point did you get in
contact with attorneys so I didn't reach
out to them
um I didn't really care the uh
the innkeepers that worked at Hicksville
before reach out to them and said we saw
some stuff that wasn't true and then
they asked is it okay if I give the
attorneys your phone number so the
attorneys reach out to me okay and when
did the attorneys reach out to you May
3rd May 3rd and you talked to the
attorneys at that time yeah yeah okay
not Camille but Um Geralyn okay and then
have you seen any other parts of the
trial no she instructed me not to watch
anything about it regardless of if it
was about his bill or not so I haven't
I've been since keeping off off the
internet and turning off uh anything
that seems to be like it's on social
media so I just don't watch any of that
okay
okay all right
any questions
so Mr Knight you were contacted by an
attorney from Mr Depp on May 3rd yes
okay and you said it was Carolyn Geralyn
Geralyn oh yarelyn I got it okay and
what it's pronounced Carolyn okay can
you tell us the conversation you had
with her at that time
yeah she um just asked me my
recollection of the evening and I told
her and she said
okay um would you mind testifying and I
said sure and she said uh okay well then
we're not sure if we're gonna call you
or not but just in case please don't
watch anything having to do with the
case and I said I will do
um
no how is it that
to your best knowledge how is it that
Geralyn was able to get all the how did
how did she know that you knew something
so like I said two of my innkeepers my
Innkeeper my manager had reached out to
her team
um I think through email
and one of them uh texted me and said
hey do you mind if we give Geralyn your
phone number
now you also communicated uh on Twitter
did you not about this case yeah two
weeks prior to Geralyn reaching out to
me
um
someone had made a comment about
something that happened by the fire pit
and I said that's not my recollection I
didn't see that's not that's not what I
saw
so who was it that made a comment about
something that happened at the fire pit
so once um I was told about the fact
that Hicksville was mentioned I went and
did a Twitter search of Hicksville
trailer so it was I don't know who it
was but I was just like what are they
saying about Hicksville and so that was
um why I did a search just to see
because it was
weird and fascinating because the night
to me
um wasn't that remarkable in the context
of all the different experiences I've
had at the trailer Palace so explain to
me please what you mean by you did a
trailer search so if you go to Twitter
and you put in keywords and do a search
all the tweets regarding that subjects
come up or anything with those keywords
in it so that is how I found the tweet
that I replied to okay and how many
tweets did you find that mentioned
Hicksville when you did that trailer
search probably like five or six I only
replied to one of them okay and what do
you recall those tweets saying about
Hicksville
um the one that I reply to said that uh
there was some incident by the fire pit
and uh and Johnny was yelling at Amber
um and I replied that my that I didn't
see that I was there all night and I was
you know I was working that night so I
didn't see anything like that
so your best recollection on that one
was that somebody said somebody was
testifying that Johnny was yelling at
Amber yeah and I believe
um grabbed her or something along those
lines do you recall
who said Johnny was yelling at Amber and
grabbed her I have no idea it was a
stranger so I didn't really pay
attention to who was writing it all
right you said that you responded to it
how did you respond to it I said that's
not what happened I was there all night
um
uh
yeah basically I'm paraphrasing it was
did you say anything about what you
thought happened
I just said that didn't happen I didn't
say what I mean I think I believe I said
maybe something along the lines of uh
from what I saw Amber was the one acting
jealous not Johnny
and you said this to one of the tweets
yes do you recall whether that was the
umbrella man
I don't recall that's ridiculous name
though okay so tell me about the other
five uh tweets that you would call scene
when you ran your trailer search
um I think they were similar in nature
but I didn't I don't specifically
remember the details of them uh that was
pretty much the only one I remembered
and that's the only one I replied to
do you remember anything about the other
five and what was said no okay when you
said that somebody told you about a
security guard what was your
understanding of what the security guard
said
um I just I got a text that uh somebody
in the trial
had said uh that they were talking about
the trailer Palace that during the trial
and so that's what led me to go on
Twitter and do a search
and did you have any Communications with
the two innkeepers about what you knew
or what you thought no I hadn't talked
to them in years they still haven't
regarding the case so how is it that the
innkeepers then contacted you and said
do you mind if we give you the telephone
number to the attorneys because they
still have me in their phone and
um Christy who was the manager at the
time was the one that texted me and said
um hey do you mind if we pass this along
they
um Mr depths attorneys want to talk to
you
mind if we pass what along your phone
number right but how is it that what is
the communication you had with the
innkeepers
that even LED them to understand that
you believed you had knowledge about
Hicksville the Hicksville incident
there was no conversation they knew
because they were both working that same
night Jenna was The Innkeeper and she
was there along with me that night
Christy was the one who texted me and
she had come in the following morning
for her shift and I slept over I was
living in keeper that night
so I'm trying to understand so just
based on the fact that seven years ago
they happened to know that you were
working that night nine years ago and
it's because I was there with them my
math well it's 2022 right now and that
was what year 2013 you're right okay so
how is it that out of the blue they
remembered nine years ago uh that that
you worked there that night and that you
might have some knowledge I mean to be
honest like we do get
um
celebrity sometimes but it was you know
it's not that unmemorable it's not like
it's any other night of the week so I'm
sure they remembered the specifics of
that night
had Mr Depp's attorneys ever attempted
to contact you before no
had you ever attempted to contact Mr
Depp's attorneys before no I had no
interest all right have you had any
conversations with Mr Depp's attorneys
other than the one you described with
zero one
um sense yes well I met with Camille
last night all right and what did you
what was that conversation please
describe
I just went through
um you know the story again that I had
told Geralyn
and let's let's hear what that story was
you want me to go through yes the whole
story um your honor we would object to
attorney work Friday
there's no attorney work products
that's okay
good go ahead sir yes sir
um that I
I describe like them getting to the
trailer Palace uh the
uh me showing them around the
interactions I had when I was on duty
with Mr Depp and Mr or Miss heard
um how uh the evening progressed
throughout the night the levels of
drinking and drug use that I witnessed
um
the
um
what the
state of the damaged trailer the next
morning
um and basically just yeah the details
that I I had only
um you know spent total 45 minutes to an
hour with Mr death
um I miss her throughout the eat
throughout the entire course of the
night so it was my
um recollection of those events during
that time
and what did Ms Vasquez say to you your
honor this is uh Beyond we have jacked
on the grounds that it's beyond the
scope of the boardier
whatever she said to him stating my
objection your honor okay it yes sir the
objection is that it's beyond the scope
of the wardir your honor enumerated the
three criteria which are relevant here
and this is a rebuttal witness so you're
on a whatever Ms Vasquez shared with him
is going to be very important here
because they knew by this time he was
going to be a witness so that was last
night so how does that fit into one of
the three factors of deciding whether or
not he's going to test well one of the
three factors you're well you're on a
man approached so that the witness
doesn't do okay that's fine
Mr Knight yes Miss Vasquez uh provide
you with any information
that anyone had testified to or said at
any point no she didn't talk about
anything except for asking me my
experience and and just getting a clear
understanding of what my experience was
she didn't mention anything outside of
the scope of what I saw and just ask me
for the facts and told me just tell the
truth and let me know you know do you
know what any of the witnesses said in
this trial about I mean outside of what
I described earlier with the um a friend
of mine texting that someone was talking
about trailer Palace I do not
do you know whether any of the witnesses
testified about any jealousy
other than the tweet that I replied to
no
all right
thank you your honor may be approach all
right well do you have any questions all
right sir if you could have a seat back
outside the courtroom thank you
if I leave my water yes you can leave
your water
[Music]
thank you
foreign
all right
So based on weighing the factors I'm
going to allow Mr Knight to testify if
we could get Mr Knight back in
now if I knew you were going to do a
sidebar I wouldn't have made him leave
I never know
all right so if you could just stay up
you could just stay there while we get
the jury okay all right are we ready for
the jury
okay John thank you
yeah
just we're going to swear I'm in again
in front of the jury okay
all right maybe see it all right thank
you ladies and gentlemen I apologize for
the interruption you're going to notice
as we get closer to the end of the
testimony you're probably gonna have
some more interruptions and I I
apologize for that but there's just some
matters we have to take up outside your
presence okay all right thank you all
right your next Witness
all right Mr Knight if you could come
forward to be sworn
to testify truthfully in this case in a
penalty of law
so if you have a seat
good afternoon Mr Knight good afternoon
Camille
State your full name for the record
Morgan Higby Knight
Mr Knight where are you from I live in
Los Angeles California and what do you
do for a living
so I currently own and run Hicksville
Pines bud and breakfast in Idyllwild
California and I created and ran a
Hicksville trailer Palace in Joshua Tree
California
starting in 2009.
how is Hicksville Pines bud and
breakfast different from Hicksville
trailer Palace
so Hicksville Pines bud and breakfast is
up in the mountains of Idlewild which is
a beautiful like snow Town above Palm
Springs
and um all the units are A-frames
instead of trailers which we have it's
obviously a very different climate than
Joshua Tree which is a desert area
um the rooms which are themed at both
places are trailers finished trailers
from the 50s through the 70s at
Hicksville trailer Palace so
um there's also a different kind of
amenities there's a pool and Joshua Tree
um there's a rec room up at Hicksville
Pines
when did you first become the owner of
the trailer Palace trailer Palace I
started building it in 2009 it took
about a year with uh my collaborator
Stephen Butcher and on the trailers and
we got done and opened
um in 2010.
did there come a time that you sold the
Hicksville trailer Palace yeah I did at
the beginning of 2020. I um had some
health issues and just it was too much
to run both at the same time so I chose
Ida wild because it was newer and
shinier
and just for my sake how long did you
own the trailer Palace so 10 years of us
being open and on your total
and what was the Hicksville trailer
Palace so um it started out as a artist
Retreat I was a filmmaker at the time
and wanted a place to get away and work
on film projects outside of Los Angeles
uh
I also put in a recording studio so
musicians could record records there I
had lived in New Orleans for five years
and there was an amazing recording
studio there called Kingsway where all
the musicians would come and they'd live
in this big mansion and record their
records and I just thought that was a
really neat thing for artists to be able
to get away and create their
um create whatever they were working on
over the course of the uh build out of
all the trailers themed trailers which
I'm a huge fan of this hotel called
Madonna Inn and uh so I wanted to do
really detailed themed trailers it
became too expensive to just make a
living off of an artist Retreat so I
decided before I was done to make it a
hotel as well
your job responsibilities generally
speaking when you owned the Hicksville
trailer Palace
so I would be living manager some nights
a couple nights a week I would also
drive out from Los Angeles twice a week
and bring supplies that you can't get
out in the Yucca Valley area and Joshua
Tree there's just a lot of things like
you know smart and finals Costco's and
stuff so I would drive that stuff out
there's also no uh USPS so sometimes I'd
have to get things shipped to my house
and drive them out as
uh I would also just do
um constantly building and creating new
stuff for trailer Palace whether it's
new trailers or amenities so I would be
working on that stuff as well I'm a big
fan of
the fact that Disneyland is always
making it better and better
and when you were the live-in manager
does does that mean that you you spent
the night at the Hicksville trailer
Palace yeah we had a house on site um
where the recording studio was and
there's a bedroom in there so whoever is
live-in manager those nights um stays in
the house and basically lives out of the
kitchen and everything
have you ever met the plaintiff in this
case Mr Depp I had met him really
briefly at The Viper Room in the late
90s
I worked with some of the people that
performed there and was good friends
with uh scroll Robin from The Pussycat
Dolls and some other friends and family
and postures so I was there and I met
him once how about Miss heard ever met
her I had never met her before
um they were guests at the hotel
when was the first time that you met Mr
Depp and Miss heard together
um in late May 2013 when they were
guests Mr deaths assistant Nathan had
read out the entire place so they could
have a night there in privacy
and what do you recall if anything about
Mr Depp and misheard's arrival to the
Hicksville trailer Palace
I got lost
so um
his security guard who arrived early
asked me if I could go fetch them
because he had an old car that um didn't
really fare on the dirt roads out there
which are pretty horrible so um I went
out and made sure that they got
themselves and the car back to
Hicksville safely to remember
approximately at what time that was it
was three to four in the afternoon
what was Mr def's demeanor when they
first arrived
trailer Palace he was super excited
about the place really complimentary
um
just had a lot of questions and um which
just seemed like it was in a really
great mood
how about Miss herd's demeanor anything
stick out
she was pretty quiet
um she uh just kind of didn't say that
much when I was giving them the tour of
the grounds and the trailer
and was anyone else with Mr Depp and
misheard when they first arrived
uh there's people that are arriving
throughout the afternoon so
um there was uh
um
I think 10 to 12 people total ended up
staying uh the security guard had gotten
there earlier and just to check out the
place but
um but yeah
and did I understand your testimony
previously that the entire trailer park
was rented out by Mr death and Miss
heard yeah the whole place left I
believe at the time about 25 people but
there was only 10 to 12 in this part
party
and who was part of that party besides
Mr death and misheard
um
I'm really horrible with names but I
remember one of them was uh Miss heard
sister and the security guard I
mentioned before but I honestly forgot
his name too
what happened when Mr Depp and Miss
heard first came onto the property
so
um I gave them a tour of we give all
guests a tour of their specific trailer
and the grounds and show them around the
uh when someone rents the whole place
they get another trailer called the bar
trailer which is basically a place to
set up their alcohol and stuff and some
people in the group were just putting
their beverages in that area
and where were you when Mr Depp and Miss
heard
that there come a time when Mr debb and
misheard went to the bar trailer
um I didn't notice most of the time that
my interactions with them everything's
kind of centrally located so there's a
fire pit bar trailer and picnic tables
all right in the same
area so they were generally around that
area the entire evening that I saw them
what did You observe of Mr Depp and Miss
heard as the evening progressed
um so Mr Depp was super uh
just super curious and really nice
um he was also really interested in my
Innkeeper because she was a musician so
they would talk about music a lot at one
point uh The Innkeeper who lived at the
next door property went home and grabbed
her guitar and they had sung a song or
two around the campfire
uh in the early evening there was
another instance where
Mr dap The Innkeeper her name is Jenna
and myself were talking about books and
music and misheard came over and kind of
interjected she seemed a little annoyed
that um Mr Depp wasn't spending time
with her
what about Miss heard's demeanor made
you think that she was annoyed
um I think just generally she uh
uh it's hard like she I think
I don't know it was just it was just
like a gut reaction like I I can't
describe it but
um you know
how long were you with Mr Depp and
misheard that evening
generally so throughout the course of
the evening I was probably 40 mostly
with Mr dapp but 45 minutes to an hour
total
um so it was uh
yeah that's over the whole course until
the end of the night after the check-in
okay and did you have an opportunity to
observe Mr dap interact with other
people guests on the property that
evening
yes
I saw him hang out with his security
guard at one point and
um outside of the uh time that him and
Jenna were seeing around the campfire he
was off by himself
um a lot of the time and Miss heard was
over at the uh at the
um campfire with her friends and seeming
to have a good time
and
if you haven't already can you generally
describe for the jury your observations
have misheard that evening
um yeah she was uh
she was seemed to be having a really
nice time with her friends around the
campfire
um and
yeah everyone was in a pretty good mood
did there come a time in the evening
That You observe Mr death and misheard
have a disagreement or an argument
yes
um
I was speaking with Mr Gap just
one-on-one talking about Hicksville and
um Miss heard came over and she
said that I want to talk to you and
seemed really upset about something so I
went and
um back in the house because it was
really
um they went off on their own and they
she started yelling at him and I I
didn't want to hear it it honestly was
really triggering because I've been in
uh emotionally abusive relationship
before objections move to straight
what's the objection okay sure
Mr Knight will you please just explain
for us what you observed when you saw Mr
death and misheard having an argument
yes
um
so Miss heard asked him to go talk
um off to the side and she was upset at
him and she was yelling at him and
I personally had been an objection
all right I'll sustain the objection
okay if you could just explain to the
jury
um what you observed when you saw Mr
Depp and misheard having an argument
okay
um
he was kind of cowering and seemed
almost afraid and
it was really
like
odd to see because he was older than her
obviously so
um but I just went back in the house
because I didn't object you went to what
he did all right a sustain us too
understood
so after you observed the argument fair
to say you went back to the trade to
your house on yes I did yeah okay
um what happened after that
so when I saw Mr Depp um on my next
rounds he apologized profusely and said
I'm really sorry about that and she was
upset objection your honor hearsay
sustain next question
what if any type of reaction did Mr Depp
have
he was just realizing your honor hearsay
he's gonna say it again if the reaction
it's not the statement all right if you
could make that clear yeah just what
type of physical reaction to Mr debb
have after the argument between Mr Depp
and misheard
he honestly throughout the rest of the
night became a lot more quiet and um and
was uh
just very more petulant in the beginning
of the night he
um was a lot more outgoing and
extroverted and throughout as the course
of the night went on he was less and
less so and more quiet
Did You observe any of the guests
consuming alcohol while on the property
um I assumed they were I mean people had
cups and there was alcohol set up in the
bar trailer but I didn't
physically see them pour alcohol into
their cup and kept going to the mouth
per se
did you witness Mr death drink any
alcohol that evening I couldn't say
anything about Mr death's demeanor that
made you think he was perhaps
intoxicated
yes um Madison Height went on he uh I am
a former bar owner so I'm even though I
wasn't drinking that night I'm very
familiar with the uh
signs so
um just as the night went on like I said
it became more and more quiet but he
also as we would have conversations his
uh head would kind of sway a little bit
back and forth which was a little you
know it was he was much less sharp than
he was earlier in the night
did Miss heard appear intoxicated to you
um she did uh she seemed
I think when she
was angry at him it seemed like she was
intoxicated but that's just based on my
experience and my own personal trauma
dealing with abuse
objection you're on a move to strike all
right I'll sustain the objectional
strike it from the record please
disregard that testimony
Did You observe anyone do or take drugs
I did not
did you witness Mr Depp and misheard
interact other than the argument that
you previously described for the jury
um the at the end of the night I heard a
commotion I was inside the house and
came out I couldn't tell what was going
on
um and Mr Jeff and misheard were having
a discussion about
um
about I'm not sure what but then they
went to their trailer at that point a
lot of people had already gone to bed so
um it just kind of petered out everyone
went to bed including myself and I
didn't hear anything else the rest of
the night
what time did the evening come to an end
I'd say it was almost around 3am
did you ever see Mr Depp grab anyone
leading
stained did you ever see Mr Depp become
physical with anyone objection leading
next question
did you ever witness Mr death get angry
objection leading
assistant
what if anything happened the next
morning
um the next morning we have to check out
at noon at the time uh before covid and
so around 11 o'clock one of my
innkeepers let me know that there was
some damage objection hearsay
um did something happen that caused you
to go to Mr Deb and Miss Hertz trailer
that was in 4 informed objection hearsay
it's not being offered for the truth
your owner I mean maybe we approach on
this okay sure thank you
what if anything happened the next
morning Mr Knight
uh the innkeepers let me know that there
was some damage in one of the trailers
and it happened to be Mr Depp and Miss
heard's trailer so I wanted to inspect
the uh trailer because I was extremely
worried
um all those trailers that Steve and I
worked on were like my babies and the
one they were staying in was the only
one that was mostly original and
restored 1950s Style and so I was uh
very concerned
so what did you observe when you went to
the trailer
I observed that there was a light sconce
by the bathroom in the bedroom that had
been broken off the wall and a couple
pieces were on the floor and they were
um and yeah it was basically just broken
the light fixture was hanging on the
wall still except for the pieces that
were on the floor
did you come to understand how that
happened yeah
foundation and my Foundation Associated
as a foundation how he knew
did you ask how the sconce was broken
objection hearsay sustained
how often do light fixtures in the
trailers break
um they break uh pretty
often I mean it's not like a usual thing
but things in the trailers generally get
broken because it's all finished
trailers and I would say as much as
every couple weeks there's some incident
of damage in one of the trailers in this
case Mr Depp had told me that injection
um so anyway yes
beyond the light fixture was anything
else in the trailer damaged no
everything else looks fine in fact we
have a
something we call a piggy fee uh that we
address to Guess that if there's
anything what we call inconsiderate or
unusually large messes we charge them
extra for it for 25 an hour cleaning fee
but they did not receive one of those
because everything outside of light
fixture looks fine
and what was your reaction to seeing the
damage light fixture
um to be honest I was relieved because
it was not a big deal I just talked
there was already another light in the
room so I just tucked the wires in the
wall until I had a few months later time
to
um I it was matching sconce with another
one in the room so I had to on eBay find
a matching pair that would fit there and
when I finally got around to it
I was able to get that and charge it to
uh Nathan who would whose credit card I
had
and what was your understanding of who
Nathan was Mr def's assistant okay and
what did you charge Nathan or Mr Duff
for replacing that pair of light
fixtures the pair came out to 62 dollars
while you were on site
um Mr Knight did you ever wear a mesh
shirt
absolutely never wear that
foreign
at any time during Mr Depp and misheard
stay on the property did you see Mr Depp
become physical with anyone
leading okay
I'm sorry that answer was uh I I never
saw Mr death get physical with anyone
when I saw him
thank you Foundation thank you Ryan
Mr Knight you are a pretty big fan of
Johnny Depp aren't you
I am not
to be honest
uh
throughout the evening I I sorry I just
asked you one question I didn't ask you
the rest of that I wanted to participate
in this trial didn't you
I did not I was asked by the attorney
and I wanted to they
um asked me and I said I'll be happy to
come and tell the truth you knew this
was on camera that it was being
broadcast to a lot of people and you saw
testimony did you not in this case and
you seized the moment and responded to
the umbrella guy the lead person for Mr
Depp's twitters did you not objection
your honor argumentative compound
overruled
uh Mr umbrella guy is the lead
the lead you know that he is he leads
one of the most predominant pro-depth
twitters out there I have no idea I
don't care or follow the umbrella guy
in fact you do follow
a Twitter called Johnny Depp fan don't
you absolutely not you don't that's your
testimony under oath it is my testimony
under us all right and on April 21st Mr
Depp testified in this case about
Hicksville didn't he
I wasn't here
and in fact you tweeted in response to
the umbrella guy
on April 21 22.
quote that never happened I was with
them all night Amber was the one acting
all jealous and crazy do you have any
call right in there I do recall writing
that Michelle can you bring that up
please
we're going to call it defendants 1903
1903.
and I'm going to go ahead and ask you to
redact
leaving the umbrella guy
and the date
and the bringing in the Hicksville yeah
I'm sorry
while she's working on that
did you write and direct a piece called
matters of consequence back in 1999
I did and didn't Mr Depp's first wife
lorianne Allison work as a makeup artist
on that
she absolutely did
and while we're looking at that uh
four days after you tweeted to Umbrella
man
I was umbrella guy
yeah
umbrella guy
okay
well all right now we have this up I'm
gonna ask you to take a look what his
defendant's exhibit 1903 do you see that
I do okay and that's from that umbrella
guy on 4 21 22 correct correct and it
says bringing in the Hicksville incident
accusations do you see that
I do and there's clearly Mr testifying
there likely a video right okay and you
respond that never happened I was with
them all night Amber was the one acting
all jealous and crazy do you see that
I do you're honor I'm going to move the
admission of defendants 1903 any
objection
yeah you're honor we believe the first
part of the um that umbrella guy's tweet
should be unredacted
for context oh
I have no idea what I was replying to
it's here
here's Frank hearsay and the context
of course
all right I can make that redaction
would that redaction any objection no
your honor thank you okay 1903 will be
in evidence with as redacted
yes
now so you reached out to the umbrella
guy in this text the Twitter right
I wouldn't call it reaching out
and in fact
the umbrella guy
is in Mr Mr Adam Waldman do you know who
Adam Waldman is I have no idea well he's
testified earlier that he talks to the
umbrella guy did he what he talked to
the umbrella guy yeah were you aware of
that I honestly this sounds like a like
schizophrenia okay now four days after
this
uh event where you texted in your honor
yeah it's in okay good four days after
that
you
tweeted
something pretty nasty about Elon Musk
didn't you
I did
okay thank you so you don't like Elon
Musk right objection relevance
I don't know thank you so that was uh
the context of that is that he I didn't
ask you for the content I apologize okay
um but you texted something that had
swear words in it would you agree about
Elon Musk
okay
now let's talk about your
uh Recollections here
45 minutes to an hour your recollection
is that Mr Depp actually drove there
yes what type of car was he driving an
old one that was a convertible
an old convertible I'm not a car guy so
I couldn't Express the model all right
and your recollection was this was May
of 2013. yes okay do you recall when in
May late May okay now you said that you
spent a total of 45 minutes to an hour
with Mr Depp and Ms hurt is that correct
after that mostly Mr Depp but that's
after the tour and after they were
checked in throughout the course of the
night okay and you don't recall any of
the people that were there other than Ms
heard's sister and the security guard
correct I don't recall any of their
names do you remember how many of them
were female
I believe it was predominantly female do
you remember how many males were there
I don't outside of the security guard do
you remember what any of the other
people looked like
um
they honestly just seemed like youngish
hitsters like for lack of a better term
I know that previously a couple of them
had stayed at Hicksville trailer Palace
that's how they knew about the place
okay
so you didn't you don't recall seeing
how much anybody had to drink that night
correct I did not witness that and you
do you recall at the use of drugs at all
I did not witness that okay were you
sitting at any point with these people
at the campfire
I was not
um and when you said that uh that you
saw Miss heard and Mr dapp and Miss
heard was yelling at Mr Depp where were
they
they she pulled in uh for a chat and it
was off
um towards their trailer like a little
bit off towards the dirt how many feet
were there between campfire and their
trailer
the campfire and their trailer yes
approximately
75 okay so where in that 75 feet did Ms
heard Paul Mr Depp and yell at him and
he cowered 20. okay I'm a campfire from
the campfire so your testimony is that
Ms hurt grabbed Mr turd pulled him 20
feet over yelled at him and he cowered
yes that's that's what I witnessed and
then did they go back
I I went inside the house so you don't
know whether they returned to the
campfire or they returned to their
trailer I do not okay
um and do you know whether there were
any uh
disagreements or physical Communications
anything of that nature at the campfire
I do not do you know whether Mr Depp did
anything to anybody else at the campfire
I didn't see anything okay do you know
whether Mr Depp grabbed anybody's wrist
and told them ask them if they knew how
many pounds of pressure it took to break
their wrist
wasn't there the whole time okay do you
is it your testimony that Mr Depp and Ms
heard
went
last to their trailer everybody else
went before them they all the rest of
the people I think about half of them
had already gone to bed and they went
um they went I can't it was all around
the same time at the end of the night
that the rest kind of scattered there
might have been a couple of people that
went right after them or right before
but it was all around the same time okay
so so your recollection is that when
Amber and Johnny Depp went back to their
trailer that dissipated everybody then
left at that point yes okay now uh how
far away was your house that you were
staying in from the trailer that Amber
and Johnny Depp were staying in I'd say
it was about 75 feet away okay
um and the next time that you saw or
heard anything was when you went there
in the morning and saw the broken Scots
is that yes I didn't hear anything after
went to bed okay and that's the extent
of your knowledge yes okay
oh good questions
Mr Knight how did you get involved in
this trial
um I got a text from one of our old
employees who I didn't talk to you
actually hearsay
don't tell us what the text said just
how did you get involved I got it I got
a text from I gotta I'm still here say
you're under okay
overruled thank you go on Mr Knight I
was asked uh
apologize
um
from a former employee
and how long had it been since you had
heard from this former employee
approximately five years
and did you contact Mr Depp or any of
his attorneys objection leading
overruled
how did you get in touch with Mr Depp's
attorneys they got in touch with me I
objection hearsay overall gone Mr knight
uh they they reached out to me oh okay
that's okay I don't have an objection
right now I think don't leave tax more
next question
and how do you feel about participating
in this trial objection relevance
extremely relevant considering that they
have accused him of being thank you
how do I feel about it yeah
um I'm happy to
tell what I saw and that's the extent of
it I really don't
care
outside of that thank you very much Mr
Knight okay all right I assume witness
is not subject to recall is that correct
all right so you're free to go thank you
thank you
all right your next Witness
or is it going to be a deposition or is
it
apologies thank you uh Dr Shaw okay
calls Dr Shaw okay Dr chef
[Music]
s
thank you sir
all right yes ma'am good afternoon Dr
Shaw can you please state your name for
the record my name is Richard John
Scholl
Dr Shaw can you please describe your
educational background
um I'm a psychiatrist I went to medical
school
at the University of London in England I
went straight off to high school that's
actually the system in the British
medical system
I did two years of pre-clinical training
and then three years of clinical work
with with patients
um following that I moved to New Zealand
to do an internship
it was an internship in
neurology medicine surgery and
psychiatry
I spent three years in New Zealand and I
um
did a year of Psychiatry residency
training
um excuse me
and
following that I um excuse me
following that I moved back I moved here
to the United States for the first time
and did a residency in adult psychiatry
at the Albert Einstein College of
Medicine which is in New York
um that was four years of training
um in the Bronx
and I also did some subspecialty
training in family therapy couples and
family therapy as in my fourth year
and after that I moved to California and
I've worked at Stanford I studied at
Stanford I did a fellowship in Child and
Adolescent Psychiatry and I've been at
Stanford pretty much since then
Dr Shaw what is your current position
I'm a professor of psychiatry in the
department of Psychiatry at Stanford
I also run What's called the Psychiatry
consult service at the Children's
Hospital at Stanford
one of any professional certificate
um I have um what's called board
certification in adults and general
Psychiatry I obtained that from the
American Board of Psychiatry and
Neurology in 1991.
um and then I obtained sub-specialty
board certification in childhood lesson
psychiatry in 1993.
are you a member of any Professional
Organization
yes I am I'm a member of the American
Academy of Child and Adolescent
Psychiatry I'm also a member of the
Academy of consultation liaison
psychiatry
how long have you been practicing
psychiatry
if you include my um training in
Psychiatry residency in the US that
would be since 1985.
she's at approximately 35 years
yeah I think so
okay what percentage of your practice
involves treating patients
yeah approximately three quarters of my
time is working with patients I work in
the Pediatric Hospital treating a
combination of
mainly Children and adolescents with
severe medical conditions
but also working with parents of
children who have medical severe medical
conditions
I also consult to the pediatric
emergency room and we evaluate patients
who show up with
suicide attempts and other serious
situations
what does the remaining quarter of your
practice entail
um well as a professor I have to do a
number of academic activities so I do
research
I do a lot of teaching I give lectures I
supervise residents medical students and
fellows in psychiatry
I I do some administrative work
yeah so it's a pretty diverse you know
varied day and week
can you tell the jury a little bit about
your research and academic work
a lot of my research has involved
looking at the issue of trauma and PTSD
and parents who have medically fragile
children
a lot of these parents are naturally
really affected by their their um their
child's illness and develop trauma
symptoms
um so I've developed some interventions
to try to help parents
you know Provide support and treatment
to reduce their symptoms of trauma
have you published articles or books in
your area of expertise
yes I have I've I've published
approximately 70 or well probably closer
to 80 peer-reviewed manuscripts in
different scientific journals
I've also
published a number of book chapters on
on various topics approximately 30. and
I have um published three textbooks
um one of which has gone into a second
edition on topics that are related to my
area of expertise and
one of them actually is about the
treatment of PTSD and parents of
premature infants
have you published a book through the
APA
um actually all of those books were
published through the the APA the
American Psychiatric association they
have a publishing house and that's been
my Publishing Company
what is the APA
um the APA the American Psychiatric
association not to be confused with the
American Psychological Association is a
professional organization that
represents psychiatrists in the U.S
um the last time I looked at this I
think there's about 37 or 38 000 members
and the the APA has many different roles
one of it is advocacy in psychiatry in
in the US but it also has an important
role in terms of
education so they they host an annual
scientific meeting every year in which
psychiatrists will present their
research
it publishes a number of journals in the
field and
um
from well fairly frequently it publishes
um
guidelines for prep for professional
practice or about ethical guidelines
that they hope that members will follow
as part of their practice
what ways are you involved with the APA
um well I mentioned my publishing
um I um I also presented the scientific
meetings I I last presented
in 2010 2021 during covert was was
virtually but on the topic of group
therapy for parents with trauma symptoms
um I you know I follow the APA and the
various guidelines I think it's a really
influential and important
um
Institution
going back to your credentials what if
any professional Awards have you
received
um I've
several teaching awards at Stanford
University and um
my the American Academy of chart and
Adolescent Psychiatry that I mentioned
um honored me with an award for service
to my specialty
several years ago I don't remember
exactly when
have you given any public presentations
in the field of psychiatry
yes I um that's part of our work as a
academic psychiatrist is to to lecture
to give presentations
so I I present fairly frequently at
annual scientific meetings as I
mentioned
um I've been invited to give Grand round
presentations at different medical
centers
um
including University of Pennsylvania and
Harvard so that's just part of our
think our role is to try to educate our
colleagues about our work
have you testified as an expert in the
field of Psychiatry before yes I have on
how many occasions
um
I would estimate
um in terms of deposition and trial
testimony approximately 50 times in the
past 15 20 years
what type of cases did you testify as an
expert
they're pretty varied so um some of them
have been medical malpractice I've also
done
a number of cases evaluating victims
who've
been subject to physical or sexual
assault or trauma
what work were you asked to do in this
case
my role in this case was to give my
opinions about the testimating opinions
from of Dr Spiegel whom you heard from
yesterday morning
have you done to form your opinion
I um I was present yesterday in court
listening to his testimony I have viewed
his depositions he had two depositions
earlier this year and I I watched as
depositions
I've also read a lot of deposition
testimony for example testimony by Mr
Depp psychiatrist Dr blastein
by his physician Dr Kipper and nurse
Debbie Lloyd
I've reviewed depositions by many of the
therapists involved in this case
including
Dr Banks the relationship consultant
um
Dr
um Cohen who was misheard's therapist
and I think Dr Anderson who I think
provided some couples therapy
uh
I've also reviewed the medical records
of Dr Kipper and Dr blastein
and some various email Communications
I think a lot of the information that
has been talked about here
thank you your honor at this time we'd
like to offer Dr Shaw as an expert in
the field of Psychiatry any objection
okay
foreign
all right so any objection uh no
objection all right so so he'll be he'll
be moved as an expert thank you
to me
Dr Shaw um you testify that you observed
Dr Spiegel's testimony yesterday yes
that's correct
and to reorient the jury can you please
generally describe the main areas in
which Dr Spiegel testified
uh yes yeah objection your honor they
heard what he testified to what's his
foundation to reorient them that's okay
okay do you have an opinion of Dr
Spiegel's testimony yes I do and what is
your opinion I have a couple of primary
opinions
um the first is is that I my opinion is
that he violated the ethical principles
that are outlined in the Goldwater rule
when he gave his opinions about
um Mr Depp specifically with
relationship to
personality traits and his cognitive
abilities
my second primary opinion would be that
um there were that
the Dr Spiegel's opinions
um were unreliable and that he had
insufficient information objection or
honor all right
you're gonna approach yeah
foreign
Dr Shaw you mentioned the gold water
rule what led up to the publication of
the Goldwater rule
um the Goldwater rule
um
came about
in response to an incident that occurred
during the 1964 presidential election
when Senator Barry Goldwater was running
as a republican candidate
and there was a magazine called fact
magazine
that started a campaign to discredit
Senator Goldwater
and they obtained a mailing list from
the AMA and sent out a single survey
questionnaire to all to about 12 000
psychiatrists in the US asking if they
felt that Senator Goldwater was
fit to run for office
and about 2 000 psychiatrists responded
a thousand of whom
expressed very negative opinions about
Senator Goldwater
and made comments such as
for example he was a megalomaniac he was
a paranoid schizophrenic
that he had narcissistic personality
disorder
um and as a result of that
he was replaced as a candidate
um and then went on to sue fact magazine
for defamation of character and he was
successful in that lawsuit
um
and in response to this
incident the American Psychiatric
association that I think was really
concerned about how Psychology was being
represented and statement psychiatrists
were making about someone they had never
met or evaluated
um issued the Goldwater rule and the
main premise of the Goldwater rule was
that
um it was improper for a psychiatrist to
render a professional opinion about a
public figure
unless they had personally and closely
evaluated them
for an act
they wanted to make sure that
uh psychiatric illness wasn't being
stigmatized
they wanted to
um ensure that individuals weren't
defamed by statements made by a
psychiatrist that didn't that weren't
backed up by medical evidence
and they also wanted to preserve the
Integrity of the
psychiatric profession since
I think the public in general and a
psychiatrist speaks out publicly and
expresses an opinion a psychiatric
opinion
people generally like to take that
seriously and the APA wanted to make
sure that those opinions were credible
and could be relied upon
have there been any updates to the
Goldwater rule
yeah since um 1973 which is when the
Goldwater rule first came out
they have been a number of revisions and
Publications by the APA they called
annotations in psychiatry in which the
Goldwater rule has been better defined
and expanded in in some to some degree
so for example in 2017 in this this
publication they
the APA reasserted that it was not
ethical to provide a psychiatric or
professional opinion about someone who
had not been evaluated personally by
that psychiatrist
that it was unethical to
provide an evaluation without obtaining
consent from that individual
um
they also
sort of
really kind of defined waterproof what a
professional opinion is and that and how
they defined it is that an opinion that
a psychiatrist expresses about someone's
speech Behavior or any characteristic
about that person
if it's that opinion is made
using the expertise experience and
knowledge inherent in the practice of
Psychiatry that is considered a
professional opinion so it might include
making a diagnosis or not making a
diagnosis
and the other I think a couple of
important things about that 2017
document were that the APA
specified that if a psychiatrist is to
give an opinion about someone about the
diagnosis or personality characteristics
whatever that they have to follow an
appropriate methodology they have to do
an evaluation that follows the standard
practice of a psychiatrist here in the
U.S
and if they don't do that they are
considered to be
um
you know affecting the Integrity of
these both the psychiatrist and the
psychiatric profession
and and this revision of the Goldwater
um rule definitely received a lot of
support the
president of the APA at the time stated
that breaking the gold water rule
was
um
irresponsible
um
stigmatizing and and definitely
unethical so that was a statement very
strong statement from the president of
the APA
what other medical organizations have
weighed in on this issue
you know the number of organizations
have their own sort of version of the
Goldwater rule the American Medical
Association that represents physicians
in the U.S
has an annual meeting
um
and it's they they have what's called a
council of ethical and judicial Affairs
and they had a meeting in 2017 in
Honolulu and they came up with their own
statements about the issue of whether
Physicians can provide opinions without
directly evaluating somebody and and
their opinion was that Physicians should
refrain from
giving a psychiatric diagnosis
about any public figure including
celebrities and people in the media
are there exceptions to the Goldwater
[Music]
there are exceptions yeah and I think Dr
Spiegel had a lot to say about this
yesterday when he was saying that if you
couldn't
Express an opinion without evaluating
someone it sort of made the whole
specialty of or role of experts in the
court sort of null and void but there
are exceptions and situations in which
an expert can give testimony in court
so one good example would be if there
was a medical malpractice case or if
there was a case above that involved a
patient who had committed suicide and
the courts wanted to find out whether
the psychiatrist had followed
appropriate practice the expert can
review medical records
and can give an opinion based on those
records provided those records
have sufficient information for example
about the diagnoses about the treatment
about how the patient was responding or
not responding to treatment
did you form an opinion about whether Dr
Spiegel complied with the Goldwater rule
uh well my opinion is that he did not he
expressed a number of professional
opinions about Mr Depp
um that we heard about yesterday
and again he did so without an
evaluation without consent
um
he did not follow the guidelines of the
APA in the 2017 revision where it was
considered important that
there'd be sufficient information
obtained by that expert to give an
opinion
[Music]
so I I would definitely felt that there
his conduct unfortunately did violate
the Goldwater rule
and specifically what opinions of
uh that Dr Spiegel gave
yeah did you do you feel violent
yeah I think that well there were sort
of two primary ones the first that you
heard about was that
Dr Spiegel
had professional opinions about Mr
Depp's personality
and he talked a lot about how he
believed that Mr dip had narcissistic
personality traits
so
um and he also you know talked a lot
about narcissistic personality disorder
so narcissistic personality disorder is
a diagnosis in the diagnostic and
statistical manual it's called the DSM-5
for short it's a diagnostic manual
published by the APA objection your
owner
okay
go ahead Dr Shaw please continue sure so
I was I was just talking about
narcissistic personality disorder in the
DSM-5 so the diagnostic criteria for
that are
um I'm not going to remember every word
about this but essentially it's a a
pattern of grandiosity
a need for admiration
um
a a lack of empathy that's demonstrated
by that person since young adulthood
and the DSM-5 has nine specific criteria
and for someone to meet the diagnosis
you have to meet five of those criteria
and so when as a psychiatrist we're
trying to make a diagnosis of any
personality disorder or any diagnosis in
general
the normal
professional guidelines would dictate
that we would do a very careful
diagnostic interview and there are
actually interviews specifically written
to assess personality disorders
um it's also possible to have
um the individual fill out
questionnaires there's something called
the narcissistic personality inventory
this is a 40 item checklist that Taps
into various components of narcissistic
personality disorder
and it's also possible to get
psychological testing like the mmpi that
I think you've heard about in reference
to one of the other experts here
so with all of this information
including collateral information from
um family members
work colleagues
information of that sort it is possible
to come up with a diagnosis of
narcissistic personality disorder
so in the case of Dr Spiegel
he had none of this information even
though he came out and stated with what
he described as a degree of medical
certainty that
Mr Depp had narcissistic personality
traits
and if you remember
somewhat towards the end of his
testimony yesterday
he was asked to since he couldn't
provide any documentation from the
medical record about narcissistic
personality disorder or narcissistic
personality traits he was asked about
what is referred to a lot in this in his
testimony is record evidence
so information that he obtained from
depositions
from
text messages from
emails what what whatever
and um
so he was asked to give I think five
examples of record evidence that would
make it seem like Mr Met criteria for
narcissistic personality traits
and I'll just mention a couple of them
just just to illustrate my opinion is
that that testimony was did not really
hold together
so he stated for example that
um
one of the criteria for narcissism is
narcissistic personality disorder is a
sense of entitlement and the example of
Dr Spiegel gave
is that he believed that misheard
married him for his money
so clearly a sense of entitlement is a
from a Psychiatry perspective that's
very different from a belief that
someone wanted you
for your money
a second example that was given was that
he was asked to give an example of how
Mr Depp had shown that he was envious of
others which is another Criterion for
narcissistic personality disorder
and the example that Dr Spiegel gave
is that
Mr Depp was jealous of Miss heard
because he believed she was having an
affair with Mr Franco
now if we look at these two terms as a
psychiatrist there's a big difference
between being envious and being jealous
as a psychiatrist when I think about
Envy I think about
somebody wants something that someone
else has and it makes them judgments
he's giving his opinion as to how Dr
Spiegel violated the Goldwater rule with
respect to his testimony about
narcissistic personality traits he he
did but now sustain the objection next
question
um okay and you mentioned two major
examples um what was the second one
the second one was confusing being
envious from with being jealous oh sorry
um Dr Shaw I mean
um you mentioned two major examples of
ways uh Dr Spiegel violated the
Goldwater rule what is this second oh
sure
um so the other big category had to do
with
um Dr Spiegel's evaluation of Mr dipp's
cognitive abilities
and he his General opinion was that Mr
Depp had
um deficits in his memory in his
attention in his processing speed
in his he that he had word finding
difficulties
um again Dr Spiegel did not evaluate Mr
dipp and the
information that he relied upon
um there were two two pieces of
information the first was that he
watched a very long deposition that Mr
Depp gave
um the day after I think he had flown
back from London to the East Coast
and
um he made observations about Mr death's
behavior in that on in that deposition
um and felt that he could opine or give
an opinion about processing speed and
other other cognitive aspects
he also made reference to something you
heard about yesterday this thing called
the mini mental status examination this
is a brief screen for
um memory and cognitive functioning that
is often done
and
he testified that Dr blastein had
administered the many mental status
examination
and although
you know from the records all we know is
the objection your honor
sustain the objection
um Dr Shah without going into Dr
bloustein's record what information does
a mini mental exam provide objection
your honor is beyond the scope of
overruled as to that limited question
yeah so the mini mental status is
um it's it's a series of about
10 or 11 questions and tasks that
someone completes and you get a score
out of 30. what doctor Spiegel testified
was that Mr Depp could not recall three
words after five minutes
and he used that as an example of Mr dip
having cognitive deficits that he
specifically attributed to Mr Depp's
alcohol and substance abuse
and
um
he really did not have such information
that I I liken a mini mental status exam
it's like taking someone's temperature
if it's elevated injection
I'll sustain the objection
um now it's probably a good time for a
break okay sure all right ladies and
gentlemen I know you had a break but we
didn't so we're gonna go ahead and take
our afternoon break for 15 minutes do
not discuss the case and do not do any
outside research okay you can see it
right there doctor
thank you
all right your excuse for 15 minutes too
sir doctor okay we'll come back at 4 17
then finish the day okay
all right
thank you
foreign
foreign
rule limited to diagnoses
it's not it's
it's um
includes all professional opinions
do you agree with Dr Spiegel that the
Goldwater rule doesn't apply to expert
Witnesses
I I don't agree now
how could Dr Spiegel Express an opinion
without violating the Goldwater rule
um this has actually been a topic that's
been written and published about so it
is possible for someone to give
testimony
about
a matter without interviewing someone
and there's certain sort of ways that it
should be framed
so for example when Dr spieger was
testifying about
um the report that Mr Depp was unable to
recall these three objects
what he could have done is said that I
have not personally examined Mr dip so I
can't speculate about his
um cognitive state or
um
ability to to function cognitively
however
it is possible that
someone who's not able to recall three
objects could have
issues related to substance use which
was what his opinion was
however what he could what he should
have done in expressing his opinion is
then have followed up to say that in
order to really establish whether these
were relevant and significant cognitive
deficits Mr Depp should have had
psychological testing
to establish the nature of these
deficits
and he should also have added that there
are other potential explanations for
these
findings so for example it's possible
that Mr Depp objection your honor he's
now
Beatles testimony yesterday you know
he's applying as to what Dr Spiegel
could have said but he's passed the uh
whether
I'll if we can move on okay
um
who's qualified to give an opinion about
cognitive deficits and processing speed
um it would have to be someone who could
conduct the type of neuropsychological
testing that I was mentioning you can't
establish the presence of cognitive
deficits without objection a battery of
tests
thank you
you can't establish cognitive deficits
without appropriate neuropsychological
testing and that can only be done by a
psychologist or neuropsychologist so a
psychiatrist like Dr Spiegel would be
giving an opinion outside of his area of
expertise if he gave an opinion about
cognitive deficits that required
psychological testing to be further
evaluated
Dr Spiegel yesterday testified about the
practice of forensic psychiatry do you
recall that testimony yes I do what is
forensic psychiatry
a forensic psychiatry is a specialty of
Psychiatry that relates to matters on
the intersection between Psychiatry and
the law
so for example what we're doing today is
forensic psychiatry where a psychiatrist
comes into court and gives an opinion
about a matter to help the court may
come to an opinion
are there Professional Standards that
govern the practice of forensic
psychiatry
yes there are
and what organizations have issued those
standards
one of the primary organizations that
has issued guidelines about the practice
of forensic psychiatry is called the
American Academy of Psychiatry and the
law this is an organization that
represents Forensic psychiatrists
and it has published guidelines about
what constitutes
um an ethical and sound practice of
doing a forensic assessment and
providing a psychiatric opinion
so this guideline I think I think was
published in 2015
um
actually
contains many elements that are
consistent with the Goldwater rule so
for example it states that
for a forensic assessment to be done
there has to be informed consent
and there should be a very thorough
comprehensive evaluation that would
include reviewing past records past
psychiatric history
it would include doing what's called a
mental status examination which is a
careful evaluation of someone's mood
cognition things of that nature
and
um
the guidelines do state that it is
reasonable
or committed to
provide an opinion without an evaluation
but if you're going to do that
there's some things that you have to
really make clear in your opinion when
you express that opinion
and the first is that you have to
acknowledge the limitations of your
opinion
and not like Dr Spiegel say that his
opinion was held with a degree of
medical certainty
you have to explain what's missing what
data you did not have that you were not
able to rely upon in coming to that
opinion
you also have to talk about what
additional information you would need to
come to that opinion
and even though the these guideline sets
it's permissible to do this
um the the the text is still
um I think
um
not fully in support of psychiatrists
doing this so their statements are that
opinions rendered with art a proper
database which is what we as
psychiatrists rely upon to make
diagnoses and and Give opinions
professional opinions
is questionable and not generally
recommended
did you form an opinion about Dr
Spiegel's testimony with respect to
these practice guidelines yes I did and
what is your opinion
well my opinion is that he did not
follow those guidelines so
um for example he did not have consent
he did not do
even a basic evaluation of Mr dipp
when he gave his opinions as I just
mentioned he he said they were opinions
that he had to a degree of medical
certainty and he did not
um
make any statements about what other
additional information he would have
wanted to make that opinion so for
example
when when asked about
shouldn't your psychological testing be
performed
he said most patients don't have access
to that which which is actually not at
all true I mean every medical school has
neuropsychologists that can do testing
so
I think that was
um
an unfortunate statement
[Music]
um
so so I think those are the primary ways
in which the Goldwater rule was violated
and the practice guidelines were not
adhered to
try yesterday Dr Spiegel was talking
about correlation and causation what is
the difference between correlation and
causation
objections it's not in this designation
it is we can approach and I can show you
all right
um go ahead Dr Shaw
yes so the the difference between a
correlation and causation
um correlation is a statistical
analysis of a relationship between two
different factors so in Dr Spiegel's
testimony he talked about
you know they're being a correlation
between
opinions he had about Mr dip his
narcissistic personality traits his
substance abuse things of that nature
um so a correlation doesn't say anything
about whether or not these factors
caused
that you know the behavior he was was
discussing
um perhaps one of the easiest ways I
could describe this difference between
correlation and causation is if we if we
look at the issue of of measles if
you'll bear with me so there's a
correlation between being young and
catching measles
um now we know that measles is not
caused by being young measles is caused
by a virus but young children have not
been exposed to the virus they don't
have the immunity so they have a higher
rate of measles
so the difference statistically is well
the differences is between causation and
correlation is illustrated by that
example so
another way I might put this as if
you know if we had a hundred people in a
room
just bringing it back to the issue of
ipv that Dr speaker was testifying about
let's say we had 70 people who had
all the risk factors for ipv
and 30 people who had no risk factors
for ipv
so what can we say about the those 70
people we can't say that any single one
of those people has perpetrated ipv
even though they may have all the risk
factors and if we look at the 30 people
who have no risk factors we also can't
see whether or not they have perpetrated
ipv
so the actual presence of risk factors
for ipv that Dr Spiegel was talking
about
they say absolutely nothing about what
happened in this case
thank you Dr Shah nothing further
cross-examination
good afternoon Dr Shaw good afternoon uh
you're not offering any opinion as to Mr
depth psychology correct that's correct
and
you
testified a lot about the Goldwater rule
um you
know of no case where an expert has been
excluded from testifying based on the
Goldwater rule correct
I don't know about the whole universe of
cases it's possible but I don't know
personally about one
and
and you before this case you've never
offered an opinion on the Goldwater rule
before correct that's correct
and you've never written an article on
the Goldwater rule correct I have not
and you've never given a presentation on
the Goldwater rule correct I have not
and you've never been on any committees
regarding the Goldwater rule correct I
have not
and you you agree that you've testified
that there are exceptions to the
Goldwater rule about having to interview
the subject right yes and you understand
that Dr Spiegel requested to meet with
Mr Depp twice the Mr depth decline
correct
I'm aware of that and Mr Mr Dr Spiegel
stated in his designation and it at
trial yesterday that he did not meet
with Mr Duck Right
yes okay
um
can we put up uh defendant's exhibit
1904
Dr Shaw have you have you seen the
opinions of the Ethics Committee on the
principles of medical ethics yes okay
and if you could turn to 79 of the PDF
it's
and it's actually thank you you see
where it's highlighted here
yes
and it says psychiatrists have also
argued that the Goldwater rule is not
sound because psychiatrists are
sometimes asked to run projection
hearsay
expert
without conducting an examination of an
individual examples occur in particular
in certain forensic cases and
consultative roles this objection
attempts to subsume the rule with its
exceptions what this objection misses
however is that the rendering of
expertise and or an opinion in these
contexts is permissible because there is
a court authorization for the
examination or an opinion without
examination
and this work is conducted within an
evaluative framework including
parameters for how and where the
information may be used or disseminated
you see that I do yes and and
this court authorized Dr Spiegel to
testify in this case correct
yes okay okay thank you I have nothing
further
Dr Shaw
um Mr needlehoff just asked you about
the court or authorization of Mr Depp's
evaluation are you aware that the court
has twice denied misheard's request for
an evaluation of Mr Depp I heard that
yesterday and in testimony yes okay
thank you nothing further all right
thank you sir you can either have a seat
or you can leave thank you
all right
foreign
okay
state your name and address for the
record
Jennifer Howell Los Angeles California
and what is your current occupation
I run the art of beliefs team the CEO of
the art of Elysium let me just go back
now you've indicated that that Whitney
lived with you from January
2015. no I'm sorry May 2015 to April
2016. are you absolutely certain about
those dates I am certain yes she came
and went at different periods but all of
her stuff moved out of my house April
2016.
and I'm sorry did you say you were a
hundred percent certain of that could
you answer my question
yes she did go back to
um Amber and Johnny's at different
points that she was still living with me
during that time the question I asked
because you were tracking at the same
time as Vasquez was was given an
objection was I believe that you said
you were a hundred percent certain of
those dates is that correct
all right well you previously testified
that you were the CEO for art of Elysium
is that correct that is correct and are
you still currently in that position yes
I am
have you been the CEO for art of Elysium
I am the founder of the organization so
um we did our first Workshop in August
of 1997.
files the legal paperwork in February of
98 to set up a 501c3 so I guess since
the beginning of the charity
well when did you first meet Amber Heard
at the Pineapple Express premiere
is where I met she and her sister
Whitney
I remember approximately what year that
was
I believe it was around 2008
I'm sure that could be pulled it was
that La Premiere I think there was
probably multiple premieres but it was a
Los Angeles premiere of Pineapple
Express
was Miss heard there with Mr duck
no this was long before
um I was a guest of James Franco and
Amber was in the movie
and so I met she and her sister at the I
mean to be specific at the after party
of the premiere
did Miss Enriquez end up working for art
of Elysium at some point yes she did
what year did Miss henriquez begin
working with art of Elysium I believe it
was in 2014 I don't have those documents
right in front of me
um I believe it was leading into the
year Amber was receiving the award
and what was Miss henriques's position
at Art of Elysium Art Salon manager
director
does Mr Mika still work for articlesia
no
when did that end
[Music]
oh 2015 I believe
each time you saw Mr Depp did you ever
see him doing any illicit illegal drugs
never
did you ever see him consuming excessive
amounts of alcohol
did you ever
seen Mr death appear intoxicated
no did Miss heard ever show you
photographs
of depicting injuries on her face or
body yeah
did matured ever tell you that Mr Depp
was abusive towards her
no
Mr dapp paying your legal fees is how
old for this deposition and the
testimony you've provided in the UK
action he is not
who is myself
do you feel any particular sense of
loyalty towards Mr duck
not enough
none at all do you feel any sense of
loyalty towards Miss heard
not at all
Howell do you recognize
this check
as the check that the art of Elysium
received
on behalf of Miss heard
for a donation an anonymous donation of
250 thousand dollars
yes
yes
really testified previously that
you understood
the anonymous donor was Elon Musk
true
yes
please have exhibit four brought up
and for the record it's based on JH 22
through 29.
before
foreign
do you recognize this document Miss
Howell and if you need to scroll through
the eight pages feel free
um like how can you scroll down
[Music]
yeah I recognize that
what is this
that is an email I believe I sent to
Whitney
scrolling up to the first page of this
attack
who is Marcel
parasol
sure Harrison he is one of my oldest
friends in Los Angeles who
has served as a board member of the art
of Elysium and is one of my biggest
confidants here in LA
for the course of my career
and going down to the third page of this
exhibit
thank you
[Music]
this is an email Miss Howell that you
sent to Whitney henriquez on or about
Tuesday July 28 2020 at 11 20 excuse me
at 11 02 A.M
it is
a true and accurate copy of an email
exchange
that you sent to miss Enriquez
yes I believe I'm the one who gave that
yes it is
and then did you forward
the email exchange and the attachments
to Marcel of Paracel yeah I asked him to
keep it for me
why did you send this email and letter
to miss Enriquez
because I struggled very much with what
to do in a situation that
I love someone who I know is doing
something very wrong and I know that
they're doing it because
they're trying to protect their sister
and
I'm trying to protect her and I'm just
trying to get her to wake up and do the
right thing which is tell the truth
that's the only thing that can help
everybody involved in this case
Miss Howell do you recall submitting a
witness statement
in the United Kingdom
yeah they basically just called to
verify the witness statement that was
submitted previously
and do you recognize this document to be
the witness statement
and the Declaration that you submitted
in the UK
and if you want to scroll down to look
at it
yes I recognize it
and uh
date
on this document
January 13 2021
and is this
daughter an accurate copy of the
Declaration that you submitted in the UK
proceeding on or about January 13 2021.
yes
and are all the statements in your UK
declaration accurate and true
I mean yes I signed it yes
all right let's pull up
what I believe was depth exhibit nine
it's been marked as depth exhibit nine
[Music]
seven nine
so miss Howell earlier you were shown
this document
um scrolling to the end of it
did Mr Waldman
assist you in drafting this email
absolutely not
did you speak with Mr Waldman at all
about drafting this email
about writing an email no I did that on
my own accord
did you speak with Mr Waldman at all
about contacting the ACLU
I do not recall having a conversation
with him about that and Miss Howell you
testified earlier that you received a
check from Fidelity charitable in
January of 2018 is that correct
um I don't know if I said the date but
yes I received an anonymous
donation from that check that was
submitted whatever it's on there I just
don't know the date off the top of my
head
and you testified that there was a
letter sent along with that
that said
it was on in honor of Amber Heard yes
Richard I was guaranteed 20 minutes with
them after being a act for three and a
half hours by your side the last time so
I am going to stick by what I was told
before entering this and what your side
agreed to
all right your next Witness
uh your honor Mr Depp calls candy
Davidson goldbron who is the corporate
designee of the Children's Hospital of
Los Angeles all right that's by
deposition is that correct yes right
hold on is it your understanding that
you're here to testify today on behalf
of the Children's Hospital
all right yeah so as of June 2018.
had any payments been made by misheard
to the Children's Hospital
um in connection with the
3.5 million dollar pledge aside from the
original hundred thousand dollar check
from Mr White in August in 2016.
yes there was a payment
um a gift on January 9th
2018
and what amount
is that gift that you're referring to
250 thousand dollars
Was that gift made
is heard or on misheard's behalf
okay and what are you basing that
statement on
from fidelity
chair Fidelity charity
that um
came
to Children's Hospital
what is this document
the letter to Mr White
from myself inquiring about further
installment on the pledge
um
that had not been fulfilled and why did
you write this to Mr White on June 14
2019.
I was trying to
figure out if there were any other
payments coming
from Mr White
to fulfill the pledge because we had
because the Children's Hospital Los
Angeles had not received any other
correspondence from him
and what is this document
a lot of Children's Hospital Los Angeles
inquiring about additional uh gifts
lunch payment installments
this letter appears to be directed to
Miss Amber Heard care of Jody Gottlieb
is that correct
um who's Jody Gottlieb
in in our the Children's Hospital
our contact for Miss Amber Heard uh Miss
Gold LeBron um
why did you send this uh letter to miss
heard and Miss Godley
I was trying to see if the pledge was
going to be fulfilled or not
in your experience is it common practice
for anonymous donors when making
donations to in one paragraph state that
they wish to remain anonymous and in the
very next paragraph identify themselves
yes
that is condom
it is common for donors to want to
remain anonymous publicly but allow the
charity to know who they are
between June 2018 and the dates on which
you've sent the letters to
um Miss heard and Mr White in June of
2019 were any additional funds received
from this room now
okay so as of June 2018 a total of 250
000 had been received
as far as the Children's Hospital is
concerned from this heard
and that was the same amount that was
that had been donated a year later in
June of 2019. is that accurate
all right
as of the date of this deposition
um March 30th 2021 how much in total has
misheard
to the Children's Hospital
or this particular yes I mean for the in
her lifetime
from 2016 to present
250 000.
Miss uh Goldberg you recall we were
speaking about this letter a few minutes
ago
correct
all right and this was a letter that you
sent to Mr correct
correct
um did you ever get a response to this
letter
now
as of October of 2018 how much money
um hadness heard directly donated
to the Children's Hospital
250 thousand dollars
as of March 30th
I'm sorry I didn't hear the end of that
sorry I just realized you said October
2018.
correct
okay yeah
two hundred fifty thousand dollars
as of March 30th 2019 how much money had
misheard directly donated to the
Children's Hospital
250 000. what is your understanding
lengths of time over which misheard
pledged the gift of 3.5 million to
Children's Hospital
there was no date arrangement with Mr to
have this pledge paid off in a
particular time
if Miss heard
were to pay this the rest of the 3.5
million in two years or five years would
see a children's hospital welcome then
HLA Wilson every in any donation
that comes this way has Amber heard's
Pledge of the 3.5 million dollars to
Children's Hospital expired to your
knowledge
not that I'm aware of no that's not
expired
all right thank you
your next witness or
your honor I think we've concluded our
Witnesses for today we will have more
live Witnesses tomorrow okay all right
ladies and gentlemen that'll be the end
of your day for today again do not do
any outside research do not discuss the
case with anybody and we'll see you
tomorrow morning at 9am okay thank you
foreign
you want to have a seat for just a
moment because we do have a few propers
we're going to be done
um just just for the record we talked
about it earlier I will charge the 30
minutes extra time for today
to the plaintiffs team so we can stay on
time I understood your honor okay all
right and I believe Mr unborn you had
some properties you wanted to do
um for Testimony
for the recording a few exhibits Mr
nadelhoff is actually okay if you want
to proper testimony for the record as
the testimony that the court has
sustained objections
here are your honors
as long as you stay close to the
microphone I appreciate it
in your honor um what I was gonna what I
will do is I'll explain what we're
proctoring the evidence for and then we
have copies um good which I'll provide
to you we can I I'll provide we'll
provide them to you electronically or I
don't have another copy for you right
now but I don't care about full
providing that's fine go ahead yes sir
okay
um uh your honor for Laura Anderson on
March 31st 2022 the defendant attempted
to designate certain portions of the
deposition testimony for trial Dr Laurel
Anderson a clinical psychologist who
worked with Miss heard and Mr death Dr
Anderson testified in the therapy
session this heard reported to her that
she was slapped by Mr death that he hit
her in the head had her hair pulled by
Mr death kicked her in the leg and met
Mr Depp gave miss her bruises Miss heard
also reported that Mr Depp was the first
to initiate any violence Miss heard also
reported that she hid in the bathroom to
protect herself from Mr death Miss heard
also reported to Dr Anderson that Mr
Depp threw a phone at her on May 21st
2016 hit her and held her hair is heard
also reported to Dr Anderson that she
was a victim of that she was a victim to
Mr def's abuse the testimony is
contained in Dr Anderson's deposition
transcript which is exhibit a the court
also excluded records of Dr Anderson for
Miss hers and Mr Depp's therapy sessions
and a treatment summary which are
exhibits B and C Mr deaf objected to Dr
Anderson's testimony is described in
medical records stating that they were
here saying that they did not fall into
any exceptions including statements for
purposes of medical treatment the court
sustained the objection on the ground of
the testimonial exhibits were hearsay
for Dr Kipper on March 31st 2022 the
defendant attempted to designate certain
portions of the deposition testimony for
trial of Dr David Kipper Mr def's
position Dr Kipper testified misheard
voice concerns of Mr Depp's Behavior
while on drugs and alcohol that Mr Depp
tried to fight and push misheard while
he's attempting detox on his Island and
that she found lots of cocaine in
February 2016. Dr Kipper also testified
he told Mr Depp to quote bury the dragon
which referred to the bad feelings that
Mr death has inside him this testimony
is contained in Dr Kipper's deposition
transcript which is exhibit d
Dr Kipper also testified about an email
he wrote explaining Mr def's detox
treatment in the email Dr Kipper wrote
to Mr deaf sister that Mr Depp had
fundamental issues with anger
romanticized the drug culture and had no
patience if his needs were not met this
email is Exhibit C Mr exhibit e Mr Depp
objected to Dr Kipper's testimony and
the email stating it was hearsay that it
did not fall into any exceptions
including statements for purposes of
medical treatment the court sustained
the objection on the ground that the
testimony and Exhibits were hearsay
uh Deborah loy on March 31st 2022 the
defendant attempted to designate certain
portions of the deposition testimony for
trial of Debbie Lloyd Mr Depp's nurse
Miss Lloyd testified misheard voiced
concerns about Mr Depp's Behavior while
on drugs and alcohol and that Mr Depp
worked himself up into a rage and was
trying to fight Miss heard while he's
attempting detox on his Island his
testimony is contained in this Lloyd's
deposition transcript which which is
exhibit F also miss Lloyd kept nursing
notes on these issues that she testified
to which is exhibit G Mr Depp objected
to miss Lloyd's testimony in portions of
the nursing note stating it was hearsay
that did not fall into any exceptions
including statements for purposes of
medical treatment the court sustained
the objection on the ground that the
testimonial portions of the nursing
notes were hearsay
on March 31st and April 1st 2022 the
defendant attempted to designate certain
portions of the deposition testimony for
trial of Miss velotti Miss herds and Mr
Depp's nurse Miss fellati testified that
Miss heard reported to her on December
16 2015 that Mr Depp head-butted
misheard in the forehead this also was
contained in Miss fellati's nursing
notes which is exhibit h
Miss velotti further testified that Miss
herb reported being freaked out after
the December 2015 incident and testified
to text messages between herself and
misheard or misheard reported the
incident of abuse these text messages or
exhibits I J K L and Ms fellati also
testified on that on May 21 2016 Miss
heard reported that Mr Depp became
completely delusional and crazed and hit
Miss heard in the face while she was on
the phone with i o till it Wright Miss
fellati testified to text messages
reporting this as well which are
contained in exhibit n the testimony is
contained in Miss fellati's deposition
transcript which is exhibit o Mr Depp
objected to miss valady's testimony
portions of the nursing notes and the
text messages referenced stating it was
hearsay that did not fall into any
exceptions including statements for
purposes of medical treatment
the court sustained the objections on
the ground so that the testimony and
portions of the nursing notes and the
text messages we're hearsay
Amy Banks Dr Amy banks on April 29 2022
the defendant attempted to designate
certain portions of the deposition
testimony for trial of Dr Amy Banks a
clinical psychologist and relationship
consultant who worked with Miss heard
and Mr debb Dr Banks testified that in
therapy sessions misheard reported that
Mr Depp attacked her physically
including by hitting her with his hand
Mr Dr Banks also testified that Miss
heard reported that Mr Depp cut his
finger off and burned himself with a
cigarette Dr Banks also reported that
misheard told her that Mr Depp initiated
the violence while in a session with Mr
dapp and Mr Depp did not object to the
characterization of the violence finally
Dr Banks testified that she believed
Miss her's accounts of the violence and
that misheard was a victim of domestic
abuse this testimony is contained in Dr
Banks's deposition transcript which is
exhibit t
Mr Depp objected to Dr Banks's testimony
stating it was here say it did not fall
into any exceptions including statements
for purposes of medical treatment and
for providing improper expert opinion
the courts sustained the objections on
the grounds that the testimony about the
abuse was hearsay and that Dr Banks's
testimony that misheard was a victim of
domestic abuse was improper expert
opinion
Colonel Cowan on April 29 2022 the
defendant attestants who attempted to
designate certain portions of the
deposition testimony for trial of Dr
Connell Cowan a clinical psychologist
who worked with Miss heard Dr Cowan
testified that in the therapy session
misheard reported abuse by Mr Depp
including text messages and medical
notes were misheard reported in December
2015 that quote Johnny did a number on
me end quote this testimony is contained
in Dr Cowan's deposition transcript
which is exhibit Q is also contained in
Dr Cowan's medical notes in exhibit r at
Depp 91 22-23 and it's contained in text
messages that are exhibits s t Mr
objected to Dr Cowan's testimony stating
it was hearsay that did not fall into
any exceptions including statements for
purposes of medical treatment the court
sustained the objections on the ground
with the testimony about the abuse was
hearsay
Alan Blaustein on April 29 2022 the
defendant attempted to designate certain
portions of the deposition testimony for
trial of Dr Alan blaustine a clinical
psychologist who worked with Mr Depp Dr
blaustian testified that in the therapy
sessions Mr Depp reported that he had
cut himself as a child and burned
himself with cigarettes Dr blastian also
testified about the drugs that Mr Depp
was on as reported to him by Miss Lloyd
this testimony is contained in Dr
blaustian's deposition transcript which
is exhibit U this information was also
contained in emails which are exhibits
VW and X
Mr Depp objected to Dr blasting's
testimony regarding the cutting and
burning himself as speculation and the
testimony regarding the drugs Mr Depp
was taking is hearsay that did not fall
into any exceptions including statements
for purposes of medical treatment the
course of State sustained the objections
on these grounds
Bonnie Jacobs on May 4th 2022 the
defendant attempted to introduce into
evidence the treatment notes of Dr
Bonnie Jacobs a clinical psychologist
who worked with Miss heard the treatment
notes show misheard reporting abuse by
Mr Depp including sexual violence the
treatment notes are exhibit Y and based
on the Court's ruling the defendant did
not call Bonnie Jacobs as a witness Mr
Depp objected to Dr Jacob's notes as
hearsay they did not fall into any
exceptions including statements for
purposes of medical treatment the court
sustained the objections on those
grounds
um
I have I have some more give me a moment
as long as you don't just keep turning
up your page in that book because I'm
not staying for that it is not okay
the UK judgment on April 29 2022
misheard moved to allow evidence and
questioning regarding the UK judgment
and for admission of the Judgment itself
which is exhibit Z in support for a
motion misheard argued that Mr death had
opened the door to the admission of the
Judgment by presenting evidence of
Damages after the date of the judgment
on November 2nd 2020. for example Miss
heard observed that Mr Depp had sought
damages for losing his role in Pirates
of the Caribbean 6 a movie that has not
yet been made misheard further observed
that Mr Depp testified that the op-ed
had caused him and his family
irreparable harm there thereby
suggesting that his reputational harm
has continued to the present Miss heard
noted that Mr def's expert designation
indicated Michael Spindler relied on Mr
Depp's earnings from 2019 to 2021 when
reaching his opinion which resulted in
an amendment to the designation
um ultimately the court found that Mr
Depp had not opened the door to the
admission of the UK judgment and
overruled the motion which the court did
again today with um Mr banyas
um
opinions
finally
um
at Adam berkovici
um
on May 19 2022 misheard attempted to
call Adam berkovici who was an expert in
the policing and Los Angeles Police
Department policing of domestic violence
calls for service Mr berkovici would
have testified to his qualifications in
the field of policing and lap the
policing of domestic violence calls for
service as follows and further outlined
in Ms heard's fourth supplemental and
rebuttal disclosures dated March 31 2022
Mr berkovichi spent 30 years with the
LAPD retiring in 2012 at the rank of
Lieutenant he has extensive experience
as a patrol officer Field Supervisor
uniformed Watch Commander with his
Sergeant second and Lieutenant one along
with multiple assignments as an officer
in charge Lieutenant's second of
specialized detective units during his
tenure with the LAPD Mr berkovici held
numerous positions directly responding
to an overseeing subordinate officers
responses to the domestic violence calls
for service including as a patrol
officer supervisor Watch Commander an
assistant Watch Commander
and actually this your honor um is a
person who prepared this prepared a
longer brief of what he was going to say
I can is it okay to submit it rather
than hearing me read it all any
objection to that no objection okay okay
that's fine
um
okay you just scared me with the size of
them I understand okay all right that's
fine if you can get Jamie our our copy
of it we'll make sure it could become
part of the record as well okay all
right do you have any propers Mr two
that you need to
at this point not at this time your
honor thank you all right then I think
there's just a couple things I need from
you like tomorrow let me uh by the end
of the of the day tomorrow if I could
get clean jury instructions without the
sights on them for the one set of and
admitted uh and also the verdict forms
as well if that's worked out okay
your honor we we sent revised jury
instructions um to them yesterday
morning in a revised party form today so
just waiting to do okay coordinate all
right thank you
um and you're working with Jamie about
some exhibits there's some that were
both sides noted that we're in in
evidence that are not so I want to make
sure everybody gets everything cleared
up you're caught up
okay good all right just keep that going
so we can get that make sure that's
taken care of
um as far as time left Sammy today I can
give you a rough estimate for two
reasons one you had some depositions so
make sure you give the the breakdowns to
Sammy about those and two Sammy wasn't
here today he had a mandatory CLE that
he had to do so I just did a rough
estimate and I want to qualify that as a
rough estimate
um but it looks like the plaintiff is
used about five hours today and the
defendant used about an hour and 15
minutes
okay again that's a rough estimate so
don't expect them to be the same but
Sammy's going to get to it this evening
and send you an email this evening with
the actual accurate times okay anything
else
no thank you your honor thank you all
right no your honor okay thank you have
a good evening we'll see you in the
morning you too thank you
all right